WE'LL
CALL THE A COMMITTEE OF HIGHER
ED TO ORDER. WELCOME TO THE
FINAL REGULAR SIMPLY HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER ED
COMMITTEE WHETHER YOU ARE HERE
IN PERSON WATCHING VIRTUALLY ON
THE PHONE LINE I'M GRATEFUL YOU
HAVE JOINED US HERE ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER FLOOR. PLEASE NOTE THE
FOLLOWING. SIMPLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO HAS BEEN APPOINTED BY
MISTER SPEAKER TO REPLACE THE
VACANCY TO FOR TODAY'S HEARING
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO.
WELCOME TO TODAY'S HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. I WILL NOT
GO OVER SOME KEY ELEMENTS OF
THE STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S
HEARING. DUE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN THIS
HEARING AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THIS HEARING IN PERSON. WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY.
FOR THOSE PRESENT ON THE
CHAMBER FLOOR AND IN THE
GALLERY WE'RE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND AUTHORS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTINCT
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITOL. FOR THOSE HERE TODAY
IN A HEARING. ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL
APPROACH AND WE'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING WHAT YOU FINISHED
TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. IS RICHARD OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING THE ELEVATOR USED TO
ONE PERSON AT A TIME. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR
THE STREAM FROM THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM. SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING AN A. T. AND T.
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THAT MAY BE
A SLIGHT DELAY SO AGAIN I ASK
THAT ALL INVOLVED REMAIN
PATIENT. THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THE NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. A.
H. E. D. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT C. A.
DOT G. O. V. AS WELL AS ON YOUR
TV OR MONITOR SCREEN. DUE TO
TIME CONSTRAINTS I WILL ONLY BE
ACCEPTING FIVE CALLERS IN
SUPPORT FIVE CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION AND FIVE CALLERS WHO
IDENTIFY AS WINNERS FOR EACH
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON. IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCASTS ON
YOUR SMART. PHONE DEVICES TO
REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION
PLEASE BE SURE TO MUTE YOUR
PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOUR LEAD WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU WILL RATE REMAINED ON
A LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED TO
MEET YOURSELF. UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE PLEASE
CALL THE COMMITTEE OFFICE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
THREE NINE SIX ZERO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL DO THEIR
BEST TO ASSIST YOU. PLEASE NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE THAT
THE GAP GUIDELINES FOR BILLS
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TWO HAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TO SPEAK FOR NO MORE THAN ONE
MINUTE EACH. ONE MINUTE EACH.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED
TO GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE
THAN ONE MINUTE WHEN I CALLED
FOR TWEETERS. THE MEASURE HAS
MORE THAN TWO ENTITIES AND THE
TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL
BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK. FOR ONE
MINUTE EACH. PLEASE NOTE
BECAUSE ANOTHER COMMITTEE WILL
BE HOLDING A HEARING IN THIS
CHAMBER THIS AFTERNOON. TODAY'S
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
HEARING HAS A HARD STOP TIME.
OF NO LATER THAN ONE THIRTY. OF
ONE WE MUST ADDRESS THIS WILL
ALLOW THE NECESSARY COVERT
NINETEEN. COMPLIANCE SANITATION
MEASURES TO TAKE PLACE BEFORE
THE NEXT HEARING. BECAUSE OF
THE HARD STOP TIME PUBLIC
COMMENT UNFORTUNATELY WILL BE
LIMITED TO FIVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND FIVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FOR EACH MEASURE
THAT WILL BE TAKEN UP. WHEN
CALLED UPON BY THE AT&T
MODERATOR IT WILL ONLY BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND STANCE ON THE
MEASURE THAT IS PRESENTLY BEING
DEBATED. THANK YOU FOR BEING
BURIED WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND TO ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMON. I
ASK YOU TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE STAND AND FACE
THE MICROPHONE WAS SPEAKING TO
ENSURE THAT YOUR VOICE IS
AUDIBLE AND CAN BE RECORDED.
FOR AUTHORS OF THE BILL EACH
MEMBER PRESENTED TODAY WILL
PROVIDE WILL BE PROVIDE AN
OPENING AND CLOSING STATEMENTS
YOU TO LEAD WITNESSES WILL BE
ANNOUNCED BY THE CHAIR AND AS I
PREVIOUSLY STATED THEY WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. SINCE I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE. ON QUORUM YET WE WILL-
BEGIN AS A COMMITTEE. AND LET
ME LOOK HERE. WE HAVE OUR
FOSTER- MR AS ERIN WE WILL HEAR
BILLS AND FILE ORDER. AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM ONE.
A. B. SEVEN FIVE SIX. MR ZURICH
MISTERS ERIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
PLEASE BEGIN WITH YOUR OPENING
STATE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS BILL
HEARD COLLEAGUES AB SEVEN FIFTY
SIX IS A LABOR OF LOVE- THIS
THIS THIS- THE CAL KIDS
INVESTMENT THIS BILL IS THE CAL
KIDS INVESTMENT ACT AND WOULD
LEVY A 1% FEE ON A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION THAT DOES BUSINESS.
IN CALIFORNIA ON EACH LOAN
ORIGINATED BY A PRIVATE PERSON.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF FINANCING
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FEE IS NON RECURRING SO IT DOES
NOT APPLY ON THE LOAN ANNUALLY
OR ON REPAYMENT. THE FEE IS
SOLELY INTENDED TO BE PAID BY
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTION. AND
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH BOTH
LEDGE COUNCIL AND BANKING
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE OUR
AMENDMENTS CLEARLY STATE THIS
PROVISION. SO THAT THE COST IS
NOT BORNE UPON- THE CURRENT
HOLDERS OF THE DEBT AS THEY'RE
TRYING TO FINANCE THEIR
EDUCATION I WANTED TO THANK
THIS COMMITTEE- BECAUSE- AS THE
CHAIR KNOWS I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE AREA NOW FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. WHETHER IT WAS A
B. FIFTEEN OR A. B. THIRTY
FOUR. THE IDEA AND THE CONCEPT
IS TO HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE EVERY CHILD
BORN. WILL HAVE A FIVE TWENTY
NINE ACCOUNT TO THEIR NAME.
PLACED SO THAT BY THE TIME
THEY'RE EIGHTEEN. THE FIVE
TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT WILL GROW
TO A PLACE WHERE WOULD FINANCE
THEIR EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
AND ENHANCE THEIR CAREER PATHS.
GIVEN WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH
THE COST OF EDUCATION COST OF
COLLEGE TUITION- COST OF BEING
ANY YOUNGER ADULTS BEING ABLE
TO ADVANCE AND ENHANCE THEIR
FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES IT'S
BECOMING ALL THE MORE DIFFICULT
AND CHALLENGING. FOR OUR
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS WHEN YOU
LOOK AND SEE THAT- EDUCATION
THAT INDUSTRY HAS OVER ONE
POINT FIVE ONE POINT THREE
TRILLION DOLLARS IN OUTSTANDING
DEBT IN THE UNITED STATES. AND
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION OF
THAT IS IN CALIFORNIA AND THERE
IS NO RELIEF IN SIGHT. YET WE
NEED TO COME UP STATE BY STATE
WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO SEE HOW.
OUR FUTURE GENERATIONS WILL NOT
CONTINUALLY BE BURDENED WITH A
WHOLE MORTGAGE OF EDUCATIONAL
LOANS BUT BE ABLE TO AT LEAST
START WITH A MODICUM OF AN
INVESTMENT. THAT WILL THEN HELP
THEM- CONTINUE ON WITH THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREER AND NOT BE
SADDLED WITH A SEVERE DEBT. AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS CREATE
THAT ONGOING REVENUE OF JUST
ONE PERCENT. TOWARDS FUTURE
EDUCATION- LOANS ONE TIME FEE
SO THAT THAT FEEDING GOES INTO
THE TRUST TO FINANCE THE CAL
KIDS PROGRAM ON AN ONGOING
BASIS- THIS GIRL AS I MENTIONED
IS BEING HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND IT'S GOING TO BE
GOING NEXT TO BANKING. AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE BANKING COMMITTEE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN ADVANCE THIS
WITHOUT HARMING FUTURE
GENERATION OF YOUNG BORROWERS.
WITH THAT I WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU TO ALL THE WORK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DONE- IN
IMPROVING THIS BILL AND WITH ME
IS NIGH RENO HOW BAD YOUNG WHO
IS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER- FOR
HER COMMENTS ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU- TRINITARIAN FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- UNFORTUNATELY WE
ARE HAVING- PROBLEMS WITH THE
TELEPHONE LINES AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO. TAKE A BREAK.
RECESS UNTIL THEY CAN FIX THE
TELEPHONE LINES. AND HOPEFULLY
THEY WON'T TAKE TOO LONG AND-
S. U. MAYBE NOT TO GO TOO FAR
BUT WE NEED TO TAKE A RECESS
UNTIL THEY CAN GET THE
TELEPHONE LINES FIX OKAY SO
WITH THAT. WE'RE IN RECESS.
THIS IS NICK WITH EIGHTEEN T.
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR. MY
SOUNDCHECK. YES YES YES YES YES.
THANK YOU WITNESSES LET ME
CLARIFY- THE MEETING CHAMBER IN
THE CHAIR. OKAY SORRY THAT
BETTER RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSES THOUGH HELLO EIGHTEEN
T. WE CAN HEAR YOU. THIS IS A
CHAMBER RECORD. ENDED OKAY
LOOKS LIKE WE'VE- CORRECTED THE
ISSUE THANK YOU SIR. YOU'RE
WELCOME.
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
THE ONLY LEAD WITNESS ON THE
LINE FOR A. B. SEVEN FIVE SIX.
IS MR NEW AND I'LL TRY TO
PRONOUNCE IT. NEW BEATEN. NINE
THREE NINE ARENA HOW BAD YEAH
IT'S NICE TO HAVE THAT IN A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE GLENDALE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT- IF
YOU'RE READY TO PROCEED. PLEASE
DO SO WHEN YOU'RE READY. HI I
AM NINETY NINE HARBHAJAN
GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF EDUCATION
MEMBER AND FACULTY AT CAL STATE
SCHOOL OF SOCIAL WORK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA MADE THE
CRITICAL DECISION TO ESTABLISH
CALKINS AND POWERFUL
INTERVENTION TO CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF KIDS LIVE. WITH
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE SIX NOW WE
CAN SECURE THE FUTURE OF ALL
CALIFORNIA KIDS. UNIVERSAL AS
PER CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNTS LIKE
CAL KIDS IMPROVE CHILDREN'S
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. PARENTS MENTAL
HEALTH AND RATE EXPECTATIONS
ALL OF THEIR CHILD'S FUTURE ALL
FACTORS DIRECTLY LINKED WITH
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. I DON'T
KNOW UNIFIED WE HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND HOW ARE TSC GIVE HOPE AND
TOOLS TO KIDS AND FAMILIES NOT
ONLY TO DREAM OF THE FUTURE BUT
TO PLAN FOR SUCCESS. CHILDREN
FORM IDEAS ABOUT THEIR FUTURES
VERY EARLY THEY FORM IDEAS
ABOUT THEIR CAPACITIES
POSSIBILITIES AND COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE WITH THIS BILL WE
CAN TRULY GIVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE KIDS. A HEADSTART
ELEVATING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
INTO A BRIGHTER FUTURE. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT EITHER IN ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER C. NINE- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO BACK AT CHAMBERS
ST NINE. ANY TWEENER SEE NONE
WE WILL MOVE TO THE- PHONE
LINES AT&T MODERATE REITER ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT A. B. SEVEN
FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN THEY'RE ALL THAT'S ONE
ZERO THE STATE SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. WE HAVE THREE IN
Q. SPOKE FIRST THE LINE FORTY
SIX FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FORTY SIX IS YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. WE'LL MOVE ON WE'LL GO TO
LINE. EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE.
LINE EIGHTY NINE DID YOU WANT
TO STATE SUPPORT FOR A. B.
SEVEN FIVE SIX. WE'RE GONNA SIT
HERE AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
SOME QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AT&T MODERATOR. THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN
FIVE SIX SEVEN PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN THAT OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN FIFTY SIX AM PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
ANY WITNESSES ON THE PHONE WHO
ARE TWEENER. IF YOUR POSITION
IS IN BETWEEN OR TRAINERS
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE ALL ONE ZERO IF YOUR
POSITION FOR A. B. SEVEN SIX
FIVE SIX IS A TWEENER. NO THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. HEY TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MR LIVING. SHARE AND
THANK YOU TO US OWNERS ARE IN
FOR OFFERING THIS IT'S- IT'S A
FASCINATING- CHALLENGE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING TO ADDRESS I
THINK THAT IT'S YOU KNOW IN IN
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
LEADING UP TO HERE YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA KNOWS THAT THERE'S-
SOMETHING THERE FOR THEM- WHEN
IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO GO TO
COLLEGE. IS IT'S AN ADMIRABLE
GOAL- WE NEED TO DO THIS AT THE
BACK THE COST OF COLLEGE IS
SKYROCKETING SO I FULLY SUPPORT
THAT- THAT GOAL THAT YOU HAVE
AND THEN WE NEED TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON. HOW TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THAT IT ALSO RAISES.
IN THE WAY THAT YOU WANT TO
FUND THIS WHICH I THINK HAS HAS
MANY PROBLEMS- IN THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED THIS I THINK A LOT OF
A LOT OF US RECORD RECOGNIZE
THAT. ALSO ALERTS US AND
REMINDS US ABOUT HOW WE FINANCE
HIGHER EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
SO. PEOPLE SOME PEOPLE ARE
EXPECTED TO PASTE. SOME OR ALL
OF THE COSTS OTHERS ARE GIVEN
GRANTS OR SCHOLARSHIPS. AND
DIED IN THEIR LIVING EXPENSES
WHICH ARE VERY EXPENSIVE AS
WELL WE KNOW THAT CERTAINLY IS
THE CASE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS BUT- FOR FINANCE-
HIGHER READ. ALSO WITH PRIVATE
BANKING DOLLARS REALLY- THAT
THAT. MANY STUDENTS END UP-
WITH THAT DATA SO THERE'S THE
STATE RELATED AID THERE IS THE-
PHILANTHROPIC AID THAT OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE NOW SEEKING.-AND THEN THERE IS THE BANKING
MONEY- THAT- ISSUES ALSO RELY
ON THE FUN- THAT THAT WHOLE
HIGHER EDUCATION JOURNEY. E IF
WE AD MORE STATE SUPPORT FOR
WE WOULDN'T WE WOULDN'T NEED
THEM TO DO SO HAVE ANY SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS OR INVESTMENT
ACCOUNTS- IS ONE WAY TO DO THAT
BUT HOW WE FUNDED IS REALLY
TRICKY AND THERE'S GOTTA BE A
WAY FOR PERHAPS NOT JUST THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OFFLOAD
THIS BOTH TO PRIVATE LENDERS
AND THEN TO STUDENTS TO PAY
THAT BACK- BUT TO FIGURE OUT A
DIFFERENT WAY I MEAN PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT STATE BANKS THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT HOW ELSE CAN THE
STATE FUND FUTURE. COSTS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THAN THE WAY
THAT WE'RE DOING IT- SO YOU
KNOW CONTINUE ON THIS JOURNEY
WITH THIS BILL TRY TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO FIND THIS FOR.
FUTURE STUDENTS- BUT I YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT A LOT OF US HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THERE'S NO WAY.
WE COULD ASK FOR A TAX ON BEING
SO IT'S NOT GOING TO BE PASSED
ON. TO CURRENT BORROWERS- OF
THAT MONEY OR TRYING TO GET
THROUGH COLLEGE SO- A LOT OF
WORK TO DO BUT THIS IS THE
FIRST STOP. ON THE LEGISLATIVE
JOURNEY FOR THE BILL SO LET'S
GIVE YOU SOME TIME TO WORK ON
IT THANKS. THIS REVIEW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
AND HONEST IN HIS AREA AND
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
THIS PARTICULAR BILL MY ONLY
CONCERN WOULD BE THAT- THIS
COSTS SOMEHOW GETS PASSED DOWN
TO THE STUDENTS. AND I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
ON IT AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT AND AS
WE DISCUSSED I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE VERY
CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT- BACK THE
COST NOT BEING PASSED ON TO.
STUDENTS BECAUSE AT THE END AND
THAT THE. THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL SO THANK YOU AND I. YOU
THIS BILL TO THE TO THE- THANK
YOU. WITH YOUR JOINT. I THANK
YOU- THE SEMINARS IN SO IS- OUT
REMARKABLE- ALWAYS SAID WAS SAW
MY INTEREST AS WELL HELLO- THE
PARENTS SO WOULD TO PREPARE OR-
THE NECESSARY COLLEGE OF FUN
STUFF WITH YOUR CHILDREN AND I
PREVIOUSLY INTRODUCED MYSELF
FOR- INCENTIVIZING. THE PARENTS
OR EMPLOYERS TO MECCA-
SCHOLARSHIP CONTRIBUTIONS SO
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDPARENTS ALL ENCORES AND SO
QUIET DOG CONTRIBUTE DOES DAN
OF THOSE AMOUNT NO COULD BE TAX
DEDUCTIBLE- SO WAY OF- OF
PROMISCUITY ENCOURAGING
ESTABLISHING NECESSARY
SCHOLARSHIPS THIS IS- I'M NOT
UP TO ME IS SO UNIVERSAL- EVERY
CHILD. AND- YES I ENDED UP TO
IS TO AND FORM OF A TAX IF- FOR
THE POOR STUDENTS TO HOST OFF
PRIVATE THIS AND- YEAH. IN THE
FRONT S. ONE HAVE TO PAY. 1% OF
THE SOUL WOULD IT BE ADDITIONAL
FEE TO THEM ALL. WHAT WILL IT
BE DEDUCTED FROM THEIR- AMOUNT
OF LOANS ARE THEY ARE AND- AS
SUPPOSED TO RECEIVE A SO THIS
IS A TOTALLY TARIAN TYPE OF
APPROACH AND- THIS IS MANDATING
AND DOG. AFTER IF YOU
IMPLEMENTED OUT FROM NOW NOW
EIGHTEEN YEARS LATER WE HAVE NO
IDEA. WHAT THE SITUATION WOULD
BE- IN THE COLLEGE'S TUITION
POLICY RIGHT NOW ALL SO MUCH
MOVEMENT IS GOING ON- EVEN. FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- TUITION
ISSUE BE ARE FREE OF CHARGE TO
YOU THERE ARE MANY- DIFFERENT
FORMS SO WE CAN ENCOURAGE. THE
STUDENTS- AND THE PARENTS HAVE
TO PREPARE FOR THE- NECESSARY
COLLEGE OF FUNDING BUT- THIS IS
OUR UNIVERSAL MANDATING I AM IN
THE FORM OF TAX SO. I WOULD
HAVE TO PULL. THE BILL. THANK
YOU. SURE IS THERE IN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO- GIVE US YOUR CLOSING.
REMARKS THANK YOU- FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU FOR THE ALL
THE COMMENTS- I ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH- MOST OF WHAT'S SAID HERE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE- WITH ALL
THREE SPEAKERS AND SENTIMENTS
OF THE NECESSITY OF DOING
SOMETHING TO. MAKE IT EASIER
AND AFFORDABLE FOR STUDENTS TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
COLLEGE VOCATIONAL TRAINING
TECHNICAL TRAINING WHATEVER THE
OPPORTUNITY MAYBE TO ENHANCE
THEIR CAREER. AND SO THIS. BILL
WAS AIMING. TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE IT PUTS THE
SEED MONEY FOR IT TO GROW. IT
ALSO ENCOURAGES PARENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN BECAUSE LET'S BE
CLEAR HERE. THOSE OF US WHO-
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
THAT. MODICUM OF AN INVESTMENT
FOR OUR CHILDREN'S FUTURE CAN
DO SO BUT THAT'S SPEAKING TO
LESS THAN ABOUT ROUGHLY 4% OF
CALIFORNIANS HELLO CALIFORNIA
PARENTS. SO IT'S A VERY SMALL
NUMBER. AND SO IN ORDER TO
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
KIDS ESPECIALLY IN POORER
NEIGHBORHOODS TO BE ABLE. TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE
IN THE FUTURE AND ADVANCE THEIR
CAREERS THROUGH AN EDUCATIONAL
DEGREE OR ANY TYPE OF A DEGREE
THAT WILL HELP THEM. HAVE A
CAREER PATH WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE MAKE AN IMPORTANT
INITIAL INVESTMENT FOR THEM SO
THAT THEN THE PARENTS.
PHILANTHROPIC ORGANIZATIONS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN HELP FINANCE
THE REST OF THE WAY THERE- I
COMPLETELY AGREE ON THE BANKING
SIDE OF THE ISSUE OF THE
CONCERNS I TO HAVE THAT CONCERN
BECAUSE IN NO WAY WOULD I WANT
MY BILL. CREATE A FEE THAT
WOULD THEN BE IMPOSED ON THE
CURRENT GENERATION OF STUDENTS
WHO NEED THAT MONEY TO BE ABLE
TO FINANCE THEIR OWN EDUCATION
SO. OBVIOUSLY THAT IS NOT THE
INTENTION IN FACT MOST BANKS IF
NOT ALL HAVE ALREADY WITHDRAWN
THEMSELVES FROM- EDUCATIONAL
LOANS LOAN INDUSTRY- WITH WALL
WELLS FARGO BEING ONE OF THE
LAST ONES. THEY SOLD THEIR
SHARE TO NELNET LAST YEAR- AND
AS YOU SEE WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THIS INDUSTRY AT LEAST THE
BANKING INDUSTRY HAS THE C. R.
A. THE COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT
ACT THAT IMPOSES UPON BANKS TO
ACTUALLY MAKE A REINVESTMENT
BACK INTO THE POOR COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY WORK IN SO THE BANKS
ARE COVERED. THE EDUCATIONAL
LENDING INDUSTRY DOES NOT HAVE.
SUCH A GOAL. AND BEING THAT
ALMOST ALL OF THEM OPERATE
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YET REAP THE
BENEFITS OF A LARGE MARKET LIKE
CALIFORNIA. MORE THAN 10% OF
THE OUTSTANDING EDUCATION LOANS
ARE RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE'RE PAYING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OUT. AND NOT HAVING
THEM MAKE AN INVESTMENT INTO IT
SO. THIS WAS A LOFTY WAY OF
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN ACHIEVE
REVENUE AND A LOT OF WORK
REMAINS TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE DO THAT SO THAT WE
GENERATE THE REVENUE NECESSARY
FOR THE FOR THE STATE FOR THESE
CHILDREN FOR FUTURE CHILDREN TO
HAVE AN EDUCATION. BUT NOT DO
IT AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
CURRENT GENERATION OF STUDENTS
SO I SHARE THAT WITH YOU AND
I'M WORKING TOWARDS THAT GOAL
AND THIS BILL WILL MOST LIKELY
BE A TWO YEAR ENDEAVOR IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT WE CAN
DO TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL. SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTERS
ERIN I UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF
YOUR BILL AND I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. BUT I ASKED
YOU TO PLEASE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH MY COMMITTEE AND THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AS
OUTLINED ON PAGE THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS AND SINCE WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM. THE WAIT FOR A
QUORUM TO- TAKE THE VOTE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE.
TO FOR THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST
WE'LL BE HEARING A. B. ELEVEN
ELEVEN- FILE ITEM FOR AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. PLEASE PROCEED. FILE
ITEM FOR. A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
WOULD CREATE A COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING SYSTEM A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MEANING THAT
COMPARABLE COURSES WOULD HAVE
THE SAME COURSE NUMBER AT ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS TAKE COURSES
AT MULTIPLE COLLEGES WITHIN A
DISTRICT OR EVEN ACROSS
DISTRICTS WITHOUT A COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM IT IS
HARDER FOR STUDENTS TO PLAN OUT
A COHERENT ROADMAP. TURNING
THEIR DEGREE. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY HAS THE COURSE
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER IN SYSTEM
C. ID SYSTEM WHICH IS A WAY TO
IDENTIFY COMPARABLE CALMING
FORCES. HOWEVER COURSES THAT
HAVE THE SAME C. ID NUMBER OR
STILL NUMBERED DIFFERENTLY FOR
THE STUDENTS. THESE DIFFERENCES
IN COURSE NUMBERS CAN
UNINTENTIONALLY SET STUDENTS
BACK SERVING AS A BARRIER TO
TIMELY TRANSFER. IN FEBRUARY.
THE GOVERNOR'S RECOVERY WITH
EQUITY TASK FORCE RELEASED A
REPORT WHICH INCLUDED A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AIMED AT
HELPING CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS RECOVER FROM
THE PANDEMIC. ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS TO DEVELOP A
COMMON COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO
THAT STUDENTS TRANSFERRING TO
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS KNOW. AS
THEY'RE PURSUING THEIR CURSES
THAT THEY ARE MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE RECEIVING
INSTITUTIONS. MAYBE ELEVEN
ELEVEN IS BASED ON THIS
RECOMMENDATION WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ADOPT A COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM BY
STARTING WITH COURSES INCLUDED
IN THE C. ID. AND EXPANDING TO
JERK TO INCLUDE GENERAL
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AND
TRANSFER PATHWAY COURSES. THIS
BILL BUILDS UPON C. ID AND
RECOGNIZE THE C. IDEAS A
CRITICAL STEP TO DEVELOPING A
STUDENT FACING COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING SYSTEM. HAVING THE
SAME COURSE NUMBER FOR ALL
COMPARABLE COURSES AT ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD REDUCE
UNNECESSARY CONFUSION. IS
ADVISING REDUCE EXCESS CREDIT
CANNULATION AND MAKE IT EASIER
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
TO TRANSFER AND EARN THEIR
DEGREE. SEEKING STUDENTS BOTH
TIME AND MONEY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN AT T. MODERATOR THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS ON THE LINE
FOR A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN IS
GERALD RICHARDSON. THE STUDENT
ADVENTURE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND THE LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR REGION SIX
OF THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MR RICHARDSON PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. MOUNTABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHARON AND I'M FROM THE STUDENT
PAPER CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. BY PERPETRATORS WHO
POLLED PARTICULARLY HOW PRODUCT
BOX WE ARE BABY ELEVEN AND ALSO
SHARE WITH YOU HOW WE MUST BE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF THE-
PLAINLY VISIBLE. COULD SAVE ME
LOTS OF TIME MONEY AND ENERGY.
SIMILARLY TO MANY STUDENTS IN
OUR SYSTEM I HAVE TO TAKE
COURSES THAT MULTIPLE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. CONSEQUENTLY BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF COMIC WORK
NUMBER AND- ADDRESS ARE
PROTECTED WHEN DISRUPTED
REPEATING EQUIPMENT. PORTRAIT
WITH DIFFERENT PORT NUMBER.
BEFORE THEY FLY HAD NOT EVEN
HEARD OF IT ID. IN COSTLY
SYSTEM FAILURE HAS HAPPENED
MORE THAN ONCE. AND WOULDN'T
IMAGINE WAITING EXTRA FUEL IT'S
THE LIKE MY TRANSFER AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT MY
FINANCIALLY. IMPAIR COURTHOUSE
DEPARTMENT. PLEASE EXPLAIN ARE
NOT UNIQUE TO ME AND BACK TO
THE PRESIDENT'S SIGNATURE OF MY
CAMPUS STUDENT GOVERNMENT I
HEAR WAY TOO OFTEN HELPS THANK
YOU. BACK AT THE MCALESTER
PROLONGED YEAR. OR ASK THE
BRINK OF DROPPING OUT CASE FOR
PSYCH ISSUE. OFTENTIMES THESE
UNITS ARE FROM MARGINALIZED
MOVIE THE BEACH HOPING THAT
THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE. IN
THAT BAND I RESPECTFULLY URGE
AND I VOTE FOR A. B. ELEVEN
ELEVEN BECAUSE IN DOING SO YOUR
TEAM WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR
PROFIT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
RICHARDSON EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR THE SECOND LEAD
WITNESS ON THE LINE FOR A. B.
ELEVEN. ELEVEN IS BRIAN KING
THE CHANCELLOR FOR LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
CHANCELLOR GANG PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE. THE SUCCESS
OF A LARGER- SINCE IT'S VERY
INSTEAD OF A LARGE MULTI
CALIBER DISTRICT WE HAVE FOUR
SEPARATELY ACCREDITED COLLEGES.
AND ARE THE SECOND LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF THE PALACE GO TO THE
MOMENT. SO OUR FACULTY HAS BEEN
PIONEERS IN ADOPTING COMMON
COURSE NUMBER ACROSS OUR FOUR
COLLEGES AND THE BENEFITS IN
YOUR FROM A STUDENT ARE JUST
THE MPS AND REDUCING. BARRIERS
TO COMPLETION AND IN OUR LARGE
DIVERSE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM ACROSS CALIFORNIA. MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS TO ATTEND
COLLEGES OUTSIDE OF ONE
DISTRICT SO REDUCING BARRIERS
AND MAKING THE PROCESS MORE
SIMPLE IS JUST A HUGE BENEFIT.
FOR OUR STUDENTS. AND I DON'T
THINK THERE'S MUCH DISAGREEMENT
THAT SIMPLICITY BENEFITS OUR
STUDENTS BUT THE REALITY IS
WITH SO MANY DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS IN SUCH A COMMITMENT
TO A ROBUST SHARED GOVERNANCE
PROCESS. WE HAVE AN EASIER TIME
AGREEING ON A CONCEPT AND WE DO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED THE
CONCEPT AT TIMES AND THAT'S
WHERE EFFORTS WHITE AT ELEVEN
ELEVEN CAN REALLY GIVE US THE
KNOWLEDGE. AND AN INCENTIVE. TO
GO THAT FINAL MILE. I AGREE TO
THE TIME. THE ACTUAL AMPLE
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE. BENEFIT
OUR STUDENTS FOR MANY YEARS TO
COME. SO I THINK- I DON'T KNOW
HARDLY SUPPORT THE EFFORT DR
KING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS YEAH AT&T MODERATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL WE
WILL KEEP TO THE ONE MINUTE
LIMIT- EIGHTEEN T. MODERATED
THE FIRST LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE LINE FOR A.
B. ELEVEN ELEVEN THIS DOCTOR
DEBBIE KLEIN PRESIDENT OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
DOCTOR KLEIN PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DOCTOR DEBBIE KLEIN
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
PROFESSOR OF ANTHROPOLOGY AT
GAVEL IN COLLEGE. AT ELEVEN
ELEVEN ASKED THE LARGEST SYSTEM
OF HIGHER EDUCATION TO ADOPT A
COMMON COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM
WITHOUT A VIABLE PLAN FOR
DEVELOPING THE SYSTEM. EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A TRANSFER BILL
THE CSU AND UC HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT OF THE CONVERSATION AND ARE
NOT BEING ASKED TO OVERHAUL
THEIR SYSTEMS. IT STILL DOES
NOT CONSIDER LOCAL CONTROL THE
STRUCTURE OF ACADEMIC
DEPARTMENTS RETIRED NUMBERS
NEEDED DISCREPANCIES HE
QUITTING OLD WITH NEW NUMBERS
OR NEW SUPPLEMENTAL COURSES.
THIS IS NOT AS SIMPLE AS
CHANGING A NUMBER ON A WEBSITE
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
DEVELOPMENT CODING TRAINING AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT. IT WOULD DISTRACT
FACULTY AT A TIME WHEN OUR
STUDENTS NEED OUR SUPPORT AND
PRESENCE WE FACULTY NEED TO
SPEND OUR TIME IMPROVING OUR
ONLINE PEDAGOGY AND
DECOLONIZING OUR CURRICULA TO
SERVE THE MOST DIVERSE STUDENTS
IN THE NATION. WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S INTENTION HOWEVER
AT ELEVEN ELEVEN IS NOT. THE
WAY TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR
KLEIN THE SECOND LEAD WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE FOR
A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN. IS DOCTOR
DELORES DAVISON THE PRESIDENT
FOR THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DR DAVISON PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. MORNING THEY'RE
NOT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND SELF EMPLOYED STATUS ON THE
PRESIDENT TO THE ACADEMIC
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HE ORGANIZED THE
ORGANIZATION IS CHARGED IN THE
STATUTE AND THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS STANDING GUARD AT THE
REPRESENTATIVE IN ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL MATTERS THE FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND PLUS CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY. YOUR
DATA YOU THE OUR FUND SESSION
LAST WEEKEND THE DELEGATES FROM
1100215 DEGREES GRANTING
COLLEGES IN OUR SYSTEM. POSTED
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO OPPOSE
THE EIGHTY ELEVEN ELEVEN. A
LETTER DETAILING THE REASONS
INCLUDING THE RESOLUTION ITSELF
HAS BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE. IN SUMMER OPPOSITION
RAP ON SEVERAL CONCERNS
INCLUDING THE FISCAL AND
PERSONNEL THE EXPENSE OF
CREATING SUCH A SYSTEM OF TIME
WHEN COLLEGES ARE FACING
LAYOFFS. DROPPED IN ROMAN AND
FINANCIAL INSTABILITY A LACK OF
INVOLVEMENT OF THE TWO OTHER
SYSTEMS OF PUBLIC HIGHER ED.
AND REQUIREMENTS THAT COULD
IMPOSE TO CREATE A SINGLE
CALENDAR QUARTERS OR SEMESTERS
IN ORDER FOR THE SYSTEM TO WORK
ACROSS THE STATE. I AM
AVAILABLE OKAY ANSWERING
QUESTIONS AT. YOUR CONVENIENCE
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR DAY. WE WILL
NOW MOVE PUBLIC. ARE THERE C.
NO WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. IN SUPPORT. NO
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION. SAY NO
TO WINNERS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES AT&T MODERATOR. ARE THERE
ANY WITNSSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK ON A DIFFERENT
BILL OR HAVE A POSITION OTHER
THAN SUPPORT. ME REPEAT ONE
THEN ZERO TO REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM QUEUE. ALTHOUGH FIRST
ALIGNED ONE EIGHTEEN ONE ONE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
EVERYONE MY NAME IS VALERIE
JOHNSON RIGHT THERE BUT THE
TRANSFER STUDENT AFFAIRS
OFFICER WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND UC
STUDENTS WE WERE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE MEMBER I THINK ABOUT
THIS LEGISLATION AND EXPECT OUR
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FORTY SIX FOUR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FORTY SIX DO
YOU HAVE A POSITION ON A. B.
ELEVEN ELEVEN. MY POSITION IS A
POET I AM A PO THANK YOU.
BORDERLINE WANTING TO ONE
HUNDRED TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TEN MEMBERS THIS
IS DONNA HOFFMAN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF COUNCIL FOR A STRONG
AMERICA AND READY NATION IN
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHT SEVEN. TWENTY PAMELA- THE
TRAIL AND THEN WE OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. TRUMP THE PART
EIGHTY LET NOTHING. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE. ONE THIRTY ONE THREE
ZERO. LINE ONE THIRTY ARE YOU
ON MUTE. YES INTERNET CAN ON
BEHALF THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN SUPPORT OF A BI LEVEL NOT.
WELL I AM THIRTY NINE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE CHECK YOUR
DEVICE. THANK YOU MR IF YOU
WANTED TO KNOW HOW MANY MORE
LINES WILL TAKE AT THIS POINT.
I THINK- MODERATOR WE COULD
HAVE WON MORE IN SUPPORT. GOOD
THANK YOU WILL GET A LINE FIFTY
FOUR FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
GONZALEZ AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND YOU CAN
UNLOCK IT. THOSE KIND O
GOVERNOR SCOTT TO BE CO
SPONSORED AB ELEVEN ELEVEN AND
WE REQUEST NINE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT. MR
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THERE
ANY ON IN THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. YOU JUST TAKE YOUR
POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THIS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO E. B. ONE
ONE ONE ONE. FOR THE FIRST TIME
LINE FORTY SIX FOUR SIX ZERO
LINE IS OPEN. SURE YEAH THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALREADY LEAVEMANY BERSERK I
TEACH ESL AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE WHICH IS PART OF THE
LOW THROUGHOUT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB ELEVEN ELEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT ORDER ONLINE EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. SO YEAH I CAN GET CAN I
SPEAK RIGHT NOW. YES I THINK IN
OPPOSITION AND I AM AT THE END
THE COLLEGE STUDENT THANK YOU.
NEXT ONE OF NINE FORTY NINE
FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS A I GOT BACK
AND I KNOW THE ANSWER DO YOU
THINK. AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY FOUR SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GOING AWAY
AND I'M FROM THE ANTI CALLING.
AND OPPOSES THE BILL. THANK YOU
IN OUR FIFTH COMMENT WILL COME
FROM LINE SIXTY ONE SIX ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIXTY
ONE YOU MAY PROCEED. HI MY NAME
IS JEFFREY AND I MAY BE
INTERESTED IN I AM IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. GIVE YOUR POSITION AS
CLEANER FOR AB ELEVEN ELEVEN ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN THE POSITION OF
TWEENER FOR A P. ONE ONE ONE
ONE.
NOPE NO TWEETERS MR MURRAY
WHO. FIVE WE DO HAVE AND WE
JUST A MOMENT OF THEY WERE
THEIR LINES. LINE ONE THIRTY
FOUR ONE THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO AND GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS LINDA VASQUEZ AND I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
WELL WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
AND HAPPENED- AND HAVING MANY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS AT THE
OFFICE OFFICE. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
AND OFFER AMENDMENTS BUT THE
GOAL OF REACHING A SUPPORT
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER TWENTY YEAR. THIS MAN
NO OTHER TRAINERS IN QUEUE SIR
THANK YOU SO WE'LL GO NOW TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. C. NINE IF THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE- WHEN THE
TIME COMES RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
ODEN AND ENCOURAGE THE STUDENTS
FROM THE ANSWER TO REACH OUT TO
MY OFFICE WOULD LOVE TO CHAT-WITH THEM TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF. ANY CONCERNS
THEY MIGHT HAVE ABOUT CREATING
A STUDENT FACING COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING SYSTEM TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THEM. TO MOVE-
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROCESS AND BE ABLE TO TRANSFER.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS BILL. AND I WANT
TO- SHARE. THAT SOMETIMES
THINGS THAT LOOK SIMPLE OR NOT.
AND SO I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT.
COMMON CORE'S NUMBER IN WHICH
SOUNDS SO EASY. HAS THE EQUAL
LEVEL OF COMPLEXITY TO IT. I AM
SENSITIVE TO THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION AND I
TRUSTED THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAFF WILL CONTINUE TO.
OUTREACH AND FIND AREAS OF
COMMON UNDERSTANDING.
FUNDAMENTALLY STUDENTS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO REGISTER FOR THEIR
CLASSES KNOWING WHAT THE CLASS
IS WHAT THE PER RIGHT WHICH IS
OUR AND HOW THAT COURSE WILL
HELP THEM ACCOMPLISH THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS I. THINK THE
BELL BILL IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM I WILL BE
SUPPORTING VOTING AND SUPPORT.
AND WITHOUT A QUORUM WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO. YOUR NEXT BILL
MISTER BERMAN A. B. NINE TWO
EIGHT FINAL ITEM THREE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR. I'M HAPPY THE
ONLY SERVICING I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT SPECIFIED IN THE
ANALYSIS AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE MASTER PLAN
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION I'VE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM STUDENTS WHO HAVE
SHARED THEIR TRANSFER
EXPERIENCE THE MESSAGE WAS LOUD
AND CLEAR THE TRANSFER PROCESS
IS TOO COMPLEX CONFUSING AND
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE. AS
CALIFORNIA BEGINS TO RECOVER
FROM THE PANDEMIC NOW MORE THAN
EVER IT IS CRITICAL THAT
INCREASED DEGREE ATTAINMENT
IMPROVE TIME 2 DEGREES AND
CLOSE A RACIAL EQUITY GAPS
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY IT WOULD
TRANSFORM THE TRANSFER PROCESS.
THREE THREE SIGNIFICANT STUDENT
CENTERED PROVISIONS. FIRST THE
BOLD CREEDON INTERSEGMENT
ELIMINATION COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE A PERMANENT VENUE. TO
FACILITATE INTER SEGMENTAL
COORDINATION AND GREATER STATE
LEVEL ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER. AND A
FOCUS ON IMPROVING TRANSFER
OUTCOMES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
SECOND THE BILL WOULD SET A
TARGET DATE FOR CSU AND UC TO
ESTABLISH A SINGULAR LOWER
DIVISION GENERAL EDUCATION
PATHWAY THAT NEEDS TRANSFER
ADMISSION TO BOTH. GOING FROM
TWO GENERAL EDUCATION PATHWAYS
TO ONE MAKES IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS. TO APPLY TO BOTH CSU
AND UC AND KEEP THEIR OPTIONS
OPEN. THIRD THE BORDER PARK
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
BE PLACED. ON AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER PATHWAY
WHERE ONE EXISTS FOR THEIR
MAJOR. SINCE THE AT T.
GUARANTEES ADMISSION TO THE CSU
SYSTEM AND PARTICIPATING
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS. THIS
PROVISION WILL MAXIMIZE THE
PROBABILITY THAT A STUDENT WILL
TRANSFER AND COMPLETE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN A TIMELY
MANNER. EVEN AT T. DOES NOT
EXIST IN THE STUDENTS CHOSE A
MAJOR. THEN THERE IS NO AT T.
FOR THE STUDENT TO BE PLACED
ON. IMPORTANTLY STUDENTS CAN
OPT OUT. AT OUR POWER TO CHOOSE
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEM AND THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS. ALSO NOTHING
IN THIS BILL PROHIBITS A
STUDENT FROM BEING ON THE AT T.
PATHWAY AND ALSO APPLYING TO
TRANSFER. TO UC OR PRIVATE
INSTITUTION. THE TROUBLING
REALITIES OF THE STATUS QUO IS
FAILING OUR STUDENTS. ONLY 20%
OF STUDENTS FOR THE TRANSFER
GOAL SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFER
WITHIN SIX YEARS. THIS IS
SHOCKING AND UNACCEPTABLE
STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER IN
CALIFORNIA CAN DO BETTER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN THE FIRST
LEAD WITNESS AND SUPPORT. IN
THE U. WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM THERE'S A LOT MORE
RESEARCH GOOD TERRACE. THE
STUDENT CENTER IS A STATE
UNIVERSITY. MISKIN TERRACE
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THIS IS JESSE RYAN WITH
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY I WILL BE
TESTIFYING FIRST. GOOD MORNING
SHARON GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JESSE RYAN
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY A STATEWIDE
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND AND SUCCEED IN COLLEGE.
I'M ALSO A PROUD FORMER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENT REPRESENTING PART OF AN
ASTONISHING LESS THAN 3% OF
STUDENTS. THAT WILL
SUCCESSFULLY REACH THEIR
TRANSFER GOAL WITHIN THREE
YEARS OF ENROLLING. FOR LOW
INCOME FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS LIKE ME CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE
GATEWAY TO OPPORTUNITY. AND
IMPROVED ECONOMIC OUTCOMES THEY
ALSO SERVE A CRITICAL FUNCTION
IN ADVANCING EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
FOR THE LARGE BLACK IN LATIN
NEXT YOU CAN POPULATIONS THEY
SUPPORT. UNFORTUNATELY
ACHIEVING TIMELY TRANSFER
REMAINS OUT OF REACH FOR FAR
TOO MANY STUDENTS DUE TO NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN BUT RATHER
DUE TO THE COMPLEX
TRANSFORMATIONS THAT THEY MUST
NAVIGATE. TO BUILD UPON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN'S
REMARKS HIGHLIGHTING THE
DISSIMILAR TRANSFERASE THE DATA
IS EVEN MORE ALARMING FOR OUR
BLACK AND LATINX STUDENTS WELL
THAT NEXT DIDN'T REPRESENT 51%
OF STUDENTS WHO DECLARE A GOAL
OF EARNING A DEGREE IN
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFERRING. THEY
ONLY REPRESENT 35% OF STUDENTS
WHO TRANSFER WITHIN FOUR YEARS
FOR BLACK STUDENTS THIS DATA IS
EVEN WORSE. EIGHTY NINE TO
EIGHT DRAWS INTENTIONAL STATE
WIDE FOCUS TO STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSFER PROCESS
AND STREAMLINES OUR TRANSFER
PROCESS TO BE EASIER FOR
STUDENTS TO NAVIGATE BY
BUILDING ON TEN YEARS OF
PROGRESS OF THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER. THE BILL
WAS INFORMED IN TWO YEARS OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH STUDENTS
HIGHER EDUCATION PARTNERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS REGIONAL PARTNERS
AND NUMEROUS RESEARCH STUDIES
THAT MAKE CLEAR WILL PROGRESS
TO SIMPLIFY TRANSFER HAS BEEN
MADE. THE STATE NEEDS TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON CONTINUED WORKING TO
STREAMLINE THE PATH. THE DATA
IS CLEAR WE'RE AT T. PATHWAYS
ARE DEVELOPED AND MADE
ACCESSIBLE FOR STUDENTS ARE
JUST RINSE AND- BENEFITS WAS
RYAN I'M GONNA HOLD YOU TO THE
ONE MINUTE SO I'M GOING TO GO.
TO THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE- IT
IS GOOD TO. THANK YOU TINA.
GOOD MORNING MEDINA AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MIKE SEVEN THEATERS AND I'M
CURRENTLY A GRADUATE STUDENT AT
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY I
MEAN YES BANK FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT I ATTENDED CATHOLIC
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO SAVE MONEY
AND WORK FULL TIME TO PAY FOR
MY EDUCATION I WASN'T SURE WHAT
MAJOR I WAS INTERESTED IN BUT I
DID KNOW I WANTED TO TRANSFER
TO CSU. WITHOUT ACADEMIC
GUIDANCE FROM MY IMMEDIATE
FAMILY I STRUGGLE TO NAVIGATE
PLANT COURSES THEREFORE I
SOUGHT OUT APPOINTMENTS WITH
COUNSELORS AFTER AFTER MEETING
A HANDFUL OF COUNSELORS I WAS
NOT INFORMED ABOUT THE EIGHTY
IN FACT THEY PUT ME ON FOUR
DIFFERENT ACADEMIC PLANS
INCLUDING A C. T. EAT PLANTS
AFTER THREE YEARS OF MISS
GUIDANCE I FINALLY FOUND A
COUNSELOR WHO IS WILLING TO
LISTEN TO MICHAEL'S AND PUT ME
ON A PATHWAY TO TRANSFER. SHE
MAPPED OUT EACH SEMESTER FOR ME
AND I TRANSFERRED WITHIN A YEAR
WITH NINE ATTEMPTED WITH NINETY
ONE ATTEMPTED CREDITS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I WAS THRILLED TO
TRANSFER TO A SEAT TO SEE IF
YOU CHANNEL ISLANDS I AM
EXTREMELY PROUD OF WHERE I AM
TODAY ESPECIALLY WORKING AS AN
AMERICORPS VISTA COMBATING THE
PANDEMIC AT SANTA ANITA COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT I THINK
ABOUT MY PEERS WHO WEREN'T WHO
WEREN'T AS FORTUNATE AS NAFF AS
ME TO MEET WITH THE RIGHT
COUNSELORS OR GOT LOST IN THE
COMPLEX TRANSFER SYSTEM IT'S
UNJUSTIFIABLE THAT HARD WORKING
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN WHAT HAVE TO
BE LUCKY TO TRANSFER. AND
GRADUATE BUSINESS. YOUR TIME OR-
THANK YEAH. AND EIGHTEEN T.
WILL NOT TO THIS ONE AS WELL-
PORTILLO. THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. CHAMBER
MEMBERS AND SHARE MY NAME IS DR
EVANGELICAL PATILLO NINE CANCER
CENTER COUNTERPOINT EITHER A
GOLDEN WEST COLLEGE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT
IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN. WELL I
AGREE THAT THE TRANSFER PROCESS
COULD BE IMPROVED CHANGES
INCLUDED IN THE SALE ARE NOT
THE APPROPRIATE METHOD THE BILL
TAKES AWAY TO THAT CHOICE TO
DECIDE THE BEST MAJOR PATHWAY
FOR THEM BY AUTOMATICALLY
DEFAULTED AT T. ANYTHING GOES
UP PATTERN FURTHER RESTRICT
OPTIONS. AND ALREADY EXIST BUT
I GET THE- INTENTIONALLY PER MR
WHEN LACK OF. WHEN EIGHT DOES
MATCH THE THAT. AND CAREER
GOALS. THE BILL DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE REAL ISSUE WOULD
TRANSFER AND NOT THE LACK OF
SPACE FOR QUALIFIED STUDENTS AT
THE C. ISSUE. THE LACK OF-
EXTRACTION LOCALIZATION
PREFERENCES INCREASING GPA
THRESHOLD LACK OF UNIVERSAL AT
T. ACCEPTANCE. REDIRECTED THE
CAMPUS OF THAT ARE OVER A
HUNDRED MILES AWAY AND MORE ALL
LIMITED STUDENTS ABILITY TO
TRANSFER. INTO THE CHANGING THE
APPLICANT REVIEW PROCESS OR
ADDITIONAL SPACES AVAILABLE.
AFTER CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS. TRANSCONTINENTAL NOT
BE ACHIEVED I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR THE NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION IS THE
LORES DAVIS AND PRESIDENT FOR
THE ACADEMIC SENATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
DR DAVISON PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. MORE IN TERMS OF BEING A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STUFF ON IT FOR FAVORITES AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ACADEMIC CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I'M HERE
TODAY TO INFORM YOU THAT OUR
SPRING PLENARY SESSION LAST
WEEKEND THE DELEGATES FROM THE
ONE HUNDRED AND 15 DEGREES
GRANTING COLLEGES ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. STARTED BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO OPPOSE EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT AS WRITTEN A
LETTER DETAILED NOTES REASONS
INCLUDING THE REVOLUTION ITSELF
HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR OF THE
OFFICE. INFORMER OPPOSITION
RESTS ON FOUR MAJOR AREAS THE
AUTOMATIC PLACEMENT OF STUDENTS
INTO THE ATP PATHWAY THE
COMBINING ORNAMENTATION OF JEEP
PATTERN. THE LEVEL OF LOCAL
DEGREE OPTIONS INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY THE BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE AND THE CREATION OF A
NEW COUNCIL THAT INCLUDES ONLY
A FEW PRACTITIONERS FROM OUR
SYSTEM. I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU DOCTOR
GAVE. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COM. NOT SEEING ANY
WOULD IN THE AND SUPPORT. NOR
ANY WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF
THE CAMBER IN OPPOSITION. FOR
ANY CLEANERS IN THE BACK. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE PHONE
LINES EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT FOR A. B. NINE TWENTY
EIGHT WE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT A. B. NINE TWO EIGHT.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED TO ONE OR TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBER THIS IS DONNA HOFFMAN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL
FOR A STRONG AMERICA AND READY
NATION IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE HAVE
A LINE ONE ONE EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
EVERYONE THIS IS VALERIE
JOHNSON TRAFFICKING AFFAIRS
OFFICER FOR BEAUTY DIDN'T
ASSOCIATION WE ARE A PROPER
SPONSOR AND SUPPORTER TO FILL.
NEXT WE HAVE LINED ONE THREE OF
ONE HUNDRED THREE. HI THIS IS
JEFF HORN EVEN FROM THE SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
AND EIGHTY NINE. DO YOU THINK
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE ONE FOUR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WE ANGELA
REED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND THE
WESTERN ASSOCIATION. OF COLLEGE
ADMISSION COUNSELING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BABY NINETEEN. THANK
YOU AND THEN WE HAVE ONE MORE
MISTER CHAIR YES ONE MORE. I
APOLOGIZE I LOST COUNT WILL GO
ONLINE FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GOOD
MORNING CHRIS MARGINAL GONZALEZ
ON THE OTHER MALE DEATH IN YOUR
INSURANCE SCORE OF EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. NOW
WE'LL GO TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MR MODERATE. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AGAIN ONE ZERO TO
OPPOSE NINE TWENTY EIGHT. WELL
FIRST ONLINE SIXTY ONE SIX ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JEFFREY AND I MEAN
BEING IN IT AND I'M SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. LIONEL ONE THIRTY THREE
ONE THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY THIS IS HARAN SEVENTY
ON THE COLLEGE STUDENT THE
PETITION TO EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
EIGHT. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE.
ONE THIRTY SIX ONE THREE SIX.
HI MY NAME IS BILL THEY CAN
HARM TACKLING NUMBER WILL CALL
JUST- AND OPPOSITION TO NINE
TWO EIGHT. WE'RE GOING ON THE
LINE FORTY SIX FOUR SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI THANK YOU
MY NAME IS ALL RIGHT NEED TO
MAKE THE MONEY BERSERK I TEACH
ESL AT AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE
WHICH IS THE LARGEST COLLEGE
AND- THROUGHOUT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. NUMBER LINE. ONE THIRTY
ONE THREE ZERO. YES GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN DINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS DOCTOR DEBBIE KLEIN
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
PROFESSOR OF ANTHROPOLOGY AT
CALVIN COLLEGE FACTS STRONGLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU FOR PET
POSITION AS TWEENER FOR A. B.
NINE TWO EIGHT PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO PLEASE. HELLO RIGHT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
FOUR ONE THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO AND GOOD MORNING
GERMANY NOW MY NAME IS LINDA
VASQUEZ AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AS PART OF
OUR SYSTEM WIDE VISION PERFECT
BASKETBALL THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE MADE IT
A PRIORITY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO TRANSFER
ANNUALLY TO THE CSU AND UC. WE
DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
EIGHT BUT WE HAVE HAD MANY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OFFICE OFFICE AND THE
SPONSORS TO OFFER AMENDMENTS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH. THE
GOAL OF REACHING A SUPPORT
POSITION THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO ONE THREE TO ONE THIRTY
TWO. LINE ONE THIRTY TWO NEW-
TRAINER POSITION ON THIS BILL.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE. SIXTY
SEVEN SIX SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT CHILD
IRREGULAR AND BE HAPPY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE DO
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY EIGHT AT THIS TIME
BUT WE DO WANT TO THANK. THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF ESPECIALLY
FOR THEIR ATTENTION- THE
TRANSFER SPACE AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE ONE
TWO FIVE. GOOD MORNING HANNAH
BAGHDAD WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENTS TO USE ON THE GROUND
TO SPEEDING OUT OF HAVING A
POSITION. AS PART OF THE PART
OF THE CONCEPT THANK YOU. AND I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE ONE MORE.
TWEENER. IT COMES FROM A LINE
OF ONE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT ONE
FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THANK MY NAME IS MARY
MORE HELP WITH IT CFU- WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL YET
BUT WE DO PLAN TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NO
MORE CLEANER POSITIONS ARE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME SIR THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR. BUT MR BERMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE A CLOSE
YEAH AND I JUST WANNA PRECIADO-
AND THANK EVERYBODY WHO CALLED
IN TO WITNESS- TESTAMENT TO MY
WITNESS TESTIMONY SUPPORT
OPPOSED- TWEENER- GETTING HIT
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WAS MY PARTNER- ON
THIS EFFORT AND THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
BIG COMPLICATED BILL AND SO
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE WORKING
WITH ALL PARTIES- WITH IT YEAH
I KNOW THAT WE ALL SHARE THE
GOAL OF MAKING IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
TRANSFER- WE THINK WERE WERE
REALLY ON TO A GOOD SOLUTION
WITH- THE THREE COMPONENTS OF
THIS BILL. BUT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL PARTIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S DONE IN A WAY
THAT'S IMPLEMENTABLE FOR
EVERYBODY. APPRECIATE YOUR I
VOTED WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY
ARISES. THANK YOU MR BERMAN AND
I- FAILED TO. PASS THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE WERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR- COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MR BERMAN I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR THIS- BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW I WAS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INSTRUCTOR- PART TIME
FOR SEVERAL YEARS I WAS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS. AND A LONG TIME
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AND TWENTY
TEACHER. AND HAVING SAID ALL
THAT- I AGREE WITH YOU WITH
WITH YOUR INTENTION OF THIS AND
I ALSO AGREE. WITH MS RYAN
STATEMENT FROM COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THE STATUS QUO
ON THE TRANSFER. RATE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE STATUS
QUO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE. AND THAT
TOO MANY STUDENTS AND AS MISS
RYAN SAID TOO MANY STUDENTS OF
COLOR BEGIN WELL INTENTIONED
BUT WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE A FOUR YEAR DEGREE.
BUT GIVEN HOW DIFFICULT- THE
PROCESS IS THAT THEY DON'T MAKE
IT- I KNOW THAT THE- AT T.
DEGREE HAS PROVEN- SUCCESSFUL.
FOR TRANSFER AND HAS IMPROVED
THE TRANSFER RATE AND FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS I APPRECIATE
YOUR- DESIRE TO FURTHER IMPROVE
THE DEGREE.AND AND I ASK YOU
TO CONTINUE TO WORK BOTH WITH
MY COMMITTEE THE FACULTY
STAKEHOLDERS AND IN ADDRESSING
THE CONCERNS AND- FROM PAGES
EIGHT THROUGH TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS. AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS BUT I AGREE WITH
YOU- VERY MUCH THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER WE NEED TO DO BETTER I
THINK IT IS UNFAIR TO OUR
STUDENTS TO HAVE THE- KIND OF
STUFF- AND IN SOME PLACE
WITHOUT NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO.
TO TRANSFER SO THANK YOU AGAIN-
IT WILL HAVE- DO PASS WHEN WE
HAVE A- A QUORUM THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL THANK YOU
MR CHAIR. SO NOW WE WILL GO ON
TO THE NEXT BILL AND FILE
ORDER- THAT IS FILE ITEM FIVE
A. B. TWO EIGHTY NINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY NINE SIX TO ENSURE
FAIRNESS IN SCHOOL DISTRICT
MERIT SYSTEM ELECTIONS. MERIT
SYSTEMS ARE CIVIL SERVICE
HIRING SYSTEMS PREDICATED ON
ATTAINING A WELL QUALIFIED AND
REPRESENTATIVE WORK FORCE.
TODAY THERE ARE OVER NINETY K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
UTILIZING MERIT SYSTEMS TO HIRE
AND PROMOTE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES. THESE EMPLOYEES ARE
DEFINED AS NON CREDENTIALED
SCHOOL DISTRICT EMPLOYEES SUCH
AS PARA EDUCATORS OR CUSTODIANS
TO NAME A FEW. EXISTING LAW
AUTHORIZES THE ADOPTION AND
REMOVAL OF SCHOOL MERIT SYSTEMS
BY A MAJORITY VOTE. OF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES THIS BILL
WILL CODIFY EQUITY FOR THESE
EMPLOYEES DURING MERIT SYSTEM
ELECTIONS AND ADDS IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT TO THE LECTION
PROCESS. HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY IS DELORES
AROUND FLORES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND JOHN BAIRD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONERS ASSOCIATION. SO
AT&T MODERATOR THE FIRST-
WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS MR RYAN
FLORES- WHEN YOU'RE READY MISS
FLORES YOU MAY BEGIN. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF OUR
JURY AND FLORENCE REPRESENTING
C-SPAN WITH THE SPONSORS OF AB
TWO EIGHT NINE THAT PROVIDES
FAIRNESS AND MERIT SYSTEM
ELECTION. OUR SYSTEM ARE MANY
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEMS THAT
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES VOTE TO
ESTABLISH IN ELECTIONS.
ELECTIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS FAIR
AND EIGHTY TWO EIGHT NINE
REMEDIES EVEN EQUITIES INFORMED
WAY FIRST IT'S ABOUT THIS IS A
SECRET BALLOT BY PROHIBITING
ADMINISTRATORS FOR MARKING
BALLOTS. THE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES DON'T FEAR THEIR
VOTES WILL BE TRACKED. SECONDLY
INSURANCE EQUITY ON TABULATIONS
COMMITTEES BY PROVIDING
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES OF
REPRESENTATIVE. THIRD INTEREST
DISTRICT ELECTION
COMMUNICATIONS REPRESENT BOTH
SIDES FINALLY IT'S CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES TO BARGAIN THE DATE
TIME AND LOCATION OF THE
ELECTION PROVIDING THEM A POINT
IN THE PROCESS. IF YOU EIGHT
NINE ABOUT. FAIRNESS I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MS
FLOW THE NECK LEAD WITNESS IS
JOHN BAIRD LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
PERSONNEL MR BAIRD WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE BEGIN. MORNING ALL
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY MY NAME
IS JOHN BAIRD ISLAND BENDIGO.
YEAH I'M SPEAKING OF SUPPORT
WILL BE TWO EIGHTY NINE TODAY I
AM THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONERS THOSE NATION WE
REPRESENT NINETY NINE MERRITT.
SYSTEM SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I AM ALSO
A PERSONAL COMMITTEE PROMISING
THE DEAL PERSONNEL PLEASE. IN
ADDITION I WORK FOR OVER THREE
YEARS REPRESENTING CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. OR UNIONS.
BUT EXPERIENCE FROM A LIFE TO
BE USED DURING THAT TIME BUT
THE LAST THE MERITS OF BLACK
STUDENTS IS VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA I FALL SOME OF THE
MOST WORRISOME EMPLOY A GLIDE
ANY GRIEF IS PAUL EXPLAINS.
ABUSES I'VE EVER SEEN- NOT WAS
THE PERSONNEL COMMISSIONER-
DIRECTOR- MADE IT BLACK THE
DISTRICT THE FUND IT'S A
PERSONNEL COMMITTEE. FOR THESE
REASONS AND OTHER REASONS THAT
I DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO INTO.
ARE THE REASONS WHY PLEASE THE
SPCA. ARE FULLY IN COMPLETING
SUPPORTING THE RESULT FAIR AND
BALANCED MEMBERS- THAT ARE
OFFERED IN A B. TWO EIGHTY NINE
FLIES W. CUT LOOK A FAMILY
WOMAN CALDERON ACTUALLY I LIVE
ON. THANK THANK YOU MR BAIRD WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
BACK SAYING NONE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO A NON ANY
CLEANERS IN THE BACK THE
CHAMBERS SAY NINE. AT&T
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
B. TWO EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WELL THE FIRST ONLINE ONE
TWELVE ONE ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MONDAY LEVEL SHAYLA GOT
IN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY TO EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MR MATTER. THANK YOU
TO STATE A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO EIGHT NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD IT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO PLEASE. OVER A LINE
ONE FIFTY ONE ONE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WAS THE CORRECT BILL.
KNOWN FOR THE LINES IN Q. IT
ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE TWEETERS.
YOUR POSITION IS TWEENER ON AB
TWO EIGHT NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO THAT'S ONE
ZERO PLEASE. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
WE'LL GO NOW TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
C. NINE MISS CALDERON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENT. YES MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I. VOTE. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU- MISS CALDERON FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
GUIDELINES FOR VOTING THIS
MEASURE IN PART INSURERS THE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE
TO DECIDE THE MERIT SYSTEM WILL
BEST SERVE. THEIR DISTRICT AND
ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM THIS YOUR
BILL WILL HAVE A-
RECOMMENDATION OF DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU MISS
COLORADO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE NEXT
BILL AND FILE ORDER- A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE I LIVE IN
SIX. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAVANT
THIS. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ADVANTIS
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR A LONG ME TO
PRESENT SOMEBODY BUILT ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE TODAY. AS THIS
STATE FOR DECADES WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TOWARDS IMPROVING
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
HOWEVER THROUGH THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC INCREASED
RATES OF HOSPITALIZATION AND
DEATH AND UNEMPLOYMENT HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED ARE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING STUDENTS OF COLOR AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS. AS THEY
HAVE WATCHED FAMILY MEMBERS GET
INFECTED REQUIRE
HOSPITALIZATION OR EVEN DIED
MANY STUDENTS HAVE HAD TO LEAVE
COLLEGE IN ORDER TO FIND WORKS
THEY CAN HELP SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES. THIS IS- AN ABSTRACT
PROBLEM THE NUMBER STUDENTS
ENROLLING IN COLLEGE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER GRADUATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL DROP NEARLY
22% JUST LAST FALL THIS TREND
IS UNDERMINING THE CONSIDERABLE
PROCESS THAT STUDENTS OF COLOR
HAVE BEEN MADE. HAD MADE AN
ACCESS THE INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IN RECENT
DECADES AS WE ALL KNOW INSURING
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION ARE MORE AFFORDABLE
IS VITAL TO IMPROVING ACCESS TO
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
DESTRUCTIONS AND LIFE EVENTS
CAUSED BY THE PANDEMIC HAVE
MADE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR MANY
STUDENTS TO MEET CERTAIN CAL
GRANT PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS RELATING TO TIME
LIMITS FOR ELIGIBILITY
INCLUDING THOSE GREAT-
REGARDING A STUDENT'S AGE.
WITHOUT THE PER OF AN
ADDITIONAL TIME IN ADDITIONAL
YEAR TO MEET THESE CAL GRANT
REQUIREMENTS MANY STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR WILL BE
UNABLE TO ACCESS THE FINANCIAL
AID THEY NEED TO ACHIEVE THEIR
DREAMS OF HIGHER EDUCATION. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE WOULD
PROVIDE RELIEF TO THE STUDENTS
BY ALLOWING THEM TO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO MEET. I. CAL
GRANT ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS ERICA
METAL FROM THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITY. AND LAURA- CZAR-
BIDS FROM THE INSTITUTION- FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBERS
ADVANTIS EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
THE FIRST WITNESS IS ERICA
ROMERO- FROM HOPE GROUP MISS
ROMERO PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY. HEY GOOD MORNING
ERICA MERRILL BEHALF OF HOW
COOL I AM CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. AS AN ASSOCIATION OUR
MISSION IS TO CHAMPION HIS
DEMOCRATS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND A KEY PART OF THAT ADVOCACY
IS TO ENSURE THAT OUR LIVE NEXT
YOU DON'T. MANY OF THEM ARE
FIRST GENERATION AND LOW INCOME
HAVE ACCESS TO THE FINANCIAL
AID THAT IS SO CRITICAL NOT
ONLY FOR MOWING THE BUT
LOWERING THE BARRIER TO HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT ALSO SUCCEEDING
IN COMPLETING THEIR DEGREE. WE
ALL NOTICED DEMOCRATS TAKING A
DISPROPORTIONATE TOLL ON OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES OF COLOR
IN CALIFORNIA 55% OF KIDS WHO
TOLD STUDENTS ABOUT BEING. WE
KNOW FROM DATA THAT ASSET AND
KEEP APPLICATIONS DROPPED
SIGNIFICANTLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC INDICATING THAT FEWER
FOR LOWER INCOME STUDENTS PLAN
ON ATTENDING COLLEGE THIS FALL
IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE MANY
LATINO STUDENTS START THEIR
ACADEMIC CAREERS HAVE ALREADY
SEEN A SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN
THEIR OFFICE. THIS INDICATOR
MOST ECONOMICALLY INSECURE
STUDENTS ARE NOT ENROLLING IN
COLLEGE STRAIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL IN GREATER NUMBERS THAN
NORMAL WE BELIEVE THE VARIETY
OF REASONS MOST OF THEM ARE
ECONOMICS. AND A LAW STUDENTS
HAVE ONLY A YEAR AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION TO USE THEIR
CATTLE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM.
AFTER THAT TIME TO TURN INTO A
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM POOL WHERE
THERE ARE FAR TOO FEW COOK
CALIBRATE FOR THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO WANT THEM. WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
TO AT LEAST ALLOW THESE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WHO WERE
IMPACTED BY COPE WITH
ADDITIONAL TIME TO ENROLL AND
COMPLETE COLLEGE WITH ACCESS TO
RETIREMENT CAL GRANT.
DEPENDABLE BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
THE STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THE STATE IS IN AN ECONOMIC
DECISION TO ALLOW THEM TO USE
THEIR COVERAGE IN THE FUTURE WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SO THAT MORE
OF OUR STATES LOW INCOME
STUDENTS CAN COMPLETE. THEIR
DEGREE IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU.
THE YOU. WE WERE- NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT C. NO WITNESSES
IN THE BACK THE CHAMBER NEITHER
AN OFFICE OR SUPPORT NOR ANY
TWEETERS WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES AT&T MODERATOR THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE OR APOLOGIZE MISTER TERRA
THINK WE HAVE A SECOND SUPPORT
WITNESS LAWRENCE TO BORROW
CLOTHES. HI I'M HERE MAY I GO
AHEAD. IS IT ALRIGHT FOR ME TO
PROCEED- DID WE JUST HEAR FROM
YOU. DID I JUST GIVE YOU I'M
SORRY. OKAY NO PROBLEM IS THAT
RIGHT FOR ME TO PROCEED YES GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR NUMBERS LAURA BARBECUE
THAT FROM THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS INDEX BACK TO
HIGHER EDUCATION ADVOCACY
RESEARCH AND POLICY
ORGANIZATION THAT MEETS
CALIFORNIAN FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY. NAME STRONG
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE. FIFTY CAL GRANT
PROGRAM IS CRITICAL IN
SUPPORTING LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ON THEIR PATH TO HIGHER
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL AND IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT REGINA ACCESS.
FINANCIAL LIFELINE I REPEAT IT
WENT THERE THEY FOUND THE
DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC HAVE RESULTED IN
NEARLY THREE IN FIVE STUDENTS
EXPECTING TO RECEIVE THEIR
DEGREES LATER THAN PLANNED WITH
THE LATEST PARTICULARLY COMMON
AMONG STUDENTS WHO IDENTIFY AS
BLACK ATTENTION YOUR COLLEGES
AND YOU ARE TWENTY FIVE OR
OLDER. MOREOVER THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS REPORT A
DECLINE IN CONCERT AND THEN IT
BEGAN WITH STUDENTS COLOR AMONG
THOSE HARDEST HIT. OVER HALF OF
BLACK AND LATIN. EXCUSE REPORT
INCREASE IN TERMS OF. IN A AND
HALF OF STUDENTS REPORT SHOW.
WITH HAS. FINANCE SUPPORT MARK
THAN I EIGHT ELEVEN FIVE WILL
HELP YOU YOU ACT TO THE AID
THEY NEED TO STAY ENROLLED IN
ACCORD NON TUITION COSTS THAT
ENABLE ACADEMIC SUCCESS. WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR I. BOATS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MS AS
BOTH- **** AND WE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. MR
MODERATOR ANYWAY. IN SUPPORT.
Q. TO STATE SUPPORT FOR A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT A. B. ONE ONE EIGHT
FIVE. WELL FIRST TIME LINE OF
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SH MAYBE GIVE
REPRESENT ELEVATE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT VERY MUCH
SUPPORT. NEXT DEADLINE ONE
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHRISTINA
MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SIXTY ONE ONE SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. JUST BOTTLED
ALKALINE. ONE OH FIVE ONE
HUNDRED FIVE. ONE OF FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FORM OF ONLINE.
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS ROSA
DEANDRE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE ARE DRAWN TO THE
PORT OF EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE AND- SURE I'D VOTE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION.
A LOCAL CLIENT. ONE SIXTY THREE
ONE SIX THREE. ONE ONE SIXTY
THREE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH AND BLOOD AND I'M
A CURRENT STUDENT AT THE MOMENT
STAY AND I- LET'S PUT THIS UP.
WE ARE NOW TAKING CALLS FOR A
POSITION. MR MODERATOR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STAY UP THANK YOU MR IF
YOU LIKE TO STATE HER
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THAT'S ONE ZERO THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE
MINING Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
OH FOUR ONE ZERO FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI APOLOGIES I THINK
MY LINE NUMBER WHICH WILL BE
CALLED FOR THE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY MY NAME IS MELISSA
BARDO BUT THE CALIFORNIA. I
MEAN YOU CAN'T. TAKE CALLS IN
OPPOSITION- WE'VE HEARD FIVE
ALREADY IN SUPPORT SO WE'RE
JUST TAKING CALLS IN OPPOSITION
TO. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
TWEETERS. PRESERVATIONIST
TWEENER TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO.
FOR TRAINERS ON A. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE. NO LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE MR LIKE THIS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE STUDENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
STATE FUNDED FINANCIAL AID AND
JUST A QUICK TIME TO FINISH
SCHOOL AND ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS
OF A HIGHER EDUCATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE. COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ONLY MADE
DISPARITIES MORE MORE CLEAR.
AND THIS AND THE SITUATIONS FOR
STUDENTS WORKERS. THIS MEASURE
WILL HAPPILY. HELP GREATLY
ASSIST STUDENTS RETURNED BACK
TO THEIR COLLEGE PROGRAMS- IT
WILL ENJOY A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION WHEN WE HAVE A
MAJORITY- SO WE'LL GO NOW TO
THE NEXT BILLING FILE ORDER- A.
B. FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM SEVEN MR VANTAGE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN TODAY AND THINKING YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENCE WORK ON THIS BILL
BEFORE I BEGIN MY PRESENTATION
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ARE NOTED ON PAGE
FOR THE HOUSES- ONCE THE BILL
DOES REACH THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. OVER RECENT DECADES
IT HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT
UNIVERSITIES NEED TO REEVALUATE
THEIR APPROACH TO THE ISSUE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SHIFT TO
TRAUMA CENTERED POLICIES TO
BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS OF
SURVIVORS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT POLICIES THAT MAKE
SURVIVORS MORE LIKELY TO REPORT
AND FOLLOW THROUGH WILL- WHICH
CHARGES IS TO. IS THE PRESENCE
OF TRAINED SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELORS ON CAMPUSES HOWEVER
MANY COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE THEIR
POLICY IN THIS SPACE FOCUS ON
COMPLIANCE. AND ARE OFTEN AT
ODDS WITH THE TRAUMA AND
SURVIVOR CENTERED RESPONSE THAT
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS DO
PROVIDE. THIS MEANS THAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT COUNSELORS ARE OFTEN
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
SUPPORTING THE NEEDS OF
SURVIVORS AND COMPLYING WITH
CAMPUS POLICIES THAT MAY NOT
PRIORITIZE THOSE NEEDS. TO
FULLY SUPPORT SURVIVORS IN A
TRAUMA INFORMED AND SURVIVOR
CENTERED PRACTICE IT IS VITAL
THAT SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS
ARE ABLE TO FOCUS PRIMARILY. ON
PROVIDING FOR THE NEEDS OF
SURVIVORS. THE ROLE OF THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS TO
PROVIDE ALL POSSIBLE OPTIONS TO
THE SURVIVOR AND TO SUPPORT ANY
DECISION THE SURVIVOR MADE. OR
MAKES. THIS MAY EVEN INCLUDE
ACTIONS AGAINST THE UNIVERSITY
THIS MEANS THAT. THOUGH THEY
MAY BE DOING WHAT IS BEST
INTEREST FOR THE SURVIVOR OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR MAY
FEAR LOSING THEIR EMPLOYMENT OR
FACING OTHER KINDS OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. WHEN
UNIVERSITIES MAINTAIN POLICIES
THAT HAMPER THE ABILITY OF A
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR TO
OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY THEY
ENABLE A CAMPUS CLIMATE DOT
DOES CONDONE SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AND SILENCES SURVIVORS. AB
FORTY SIXTY SEVEN WILL PROVIDE
CLARITY TO SUCH SITUATIONS BY
ESTABLISHING THAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT COUNSELORS ARE
INDEPENDENT OF THE CAMPUS TITLE
NINE OFFICE. IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW SEXUAL SO CAMP COUNSELORS
TO MAINTAIN CONFIDENTIALITY
WITH SURVIVORS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW CAMPUS BASED SEXUAL
ASSAULT COUNSELORS TO HAVE
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS AND THE
ABILITY TO ACT INDEPENDENTLY
FROM THE UNIVERSITY WITHOUT
FEAR OR RICHARD GUY RETRIBUTION.
BY ENSURING THAT CAMPUS CAMPUS
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS HAVE
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO DO
THEIR JOBS WE WILL ENSURE THAT
THEY IN TURN HAVE BETTER TOOLS
TO SUPPORT STUDENT SURVIVORS
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE TODAY IS NICOLE
BUT AT A- DOCTORAL STUDENT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
SHE'S ALSO A NATIONAL SCIENCE
FOUNDATION GRADUATE RESEARCH
FELLOW WHO RESEARCH FOCUSES ON
HOW UNIVERSITIES MANAGE SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU MR RUN
THURS EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE
LEAD WITNESS MISS NICOLE THE
DERA- THIS BIGGER PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NICOLE
THERE I'M A DOCTORAL CANDIDATE
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN
AND I THIRTY CAMPUS SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. IN MY RESEARCH I'VE
SEEN THE WAY VICTIM ADVOCATES
ARE PULLED IN TWO DIRECTIONS
FOR BETWEEN ADVOCATING FOR
SURVIVORS AND PROTECTING THEIR
INSTITUTION. APPLE UNIVERSITY I
THOUGHT STUDIED PROHIBITED
ADVOCATE FROM TELLING A
SURVIVOR THAT THEIR EXPERIENCE
THAT THE DIFFERENT DEFINITION
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. OR MAKING
INFORMATION ABOUT REPORTING
PROCESS EASILY AVAILABLE AS A
RESULT MANY SURVIVORS WHO
BELIEVE THEY HAVE FILED REPORTS
CORRECTLY HAVE MADE MISTAKES
BUT THE REALTOR EFFORT. I THINK
THE MEDICAID CLIFF CORRECT
THESE MISSTEPS BUT THEY WEREN'T
ALLOWED TO HELP. THE TENSION
AND ROLLED WAVE ON MEDICARE
MANY HAVE PROBLEMS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH BECAUSE OF THEIR WORK
INCLUDING SUICIDALITY. SOME
WERE FORCED TO QUIT IN AN ACT
OF SELF PRESERVATION OTHERS
WERE PUSHED OUT WHEN THEY TRIED
TO BEND THE RULES TO SUPPORT
SURVIVORS EFFECTIVELY. AS A
RESULT THE VICTIM ADVOCACY
OFFICE BECAME MORE OF ALL THE
DOORS STAFF WHO LEFT THEIR
POSITIONS JUST BECAUSE THEY GOT
GOOD AT THEIR JOBS. THE
OPERATIVE UNDERSTAFFED A NEW
HIRES WERE UNDERPREPARED TO
NAVIGATE UNIVERSITY SPECIFIC
POLICIES AND PROGRAMMES. DID
HURT SURVIVORS THE RESOURCE OF
LEGISLATORS ARE BROUGHT TO
CAMPUS ARE OUT OF REACH WITHOUT
A TON OF VICTIM ADVOCATES. BILL
COULD CHANGE THAT AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISS MADERA- SEE NO
WITNESS. IN SUPPORT IN THE BACK
OF THE CHAMBER NO ANY WITNESS.
AND OPPOSITION OR ANY TWEETERS.
WE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
AT&T MODERATOR. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
A. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN THAT SUPPORT FOR A. B.
ONE FOUR SIX SEVEN ME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NINE ONE SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS ARE YOU AT GORDON I'M A
STUDENT OUR SECOND OF STATE
WITHIN THE COMPANY DEPARTMENT
AND I SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ONE OTHER LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
YOU MAY ALSO.
THE LADY HERE WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SIXTY TWO ONE SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ADAM MY NAME
IS KATHLEEN SAYING AND I'M AN
ALUMNI OF UC BERKELEY AND I AM
IN SUPPORT. NO FOR THE ALLIANCE
IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT AND
STRUCTURE IF WE GO NOW TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION ON A. B. ONE FOUR
SIX SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN ONE ZERO TO
OPPOSE FOURTEEN SIX SEVEN. NO
LINE TO HEAR AT THIS TIME. THIS
MATTER DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
THAT ARE TWEETERS. IF YOUR
POSITION IS TWEENER FOR A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN MAY PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL. ONE ZERO
EXPOSITION IS TWEENER. AND
THEY'RE NOT LYING TO YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU DO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. C. NINE LIZARD
RENTERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
MR VENDORS ARE LIKE THAT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND FOR YOUR CONTINUING
WORK- THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF
OF DONE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. THANK YOU FOR BIG
ALSO FOR WORKING WITH MY
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE TITLE
NINE CONCERNS THOSE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE PROCESSED IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN ORDER
FOR US TO MEET COMMITTEE
DEADLINES AND I TRUST THAT YOU
THAT YOU WILL KEEP THIS
COMMITTEE INVOLVED MOVING
FORWARD. AND I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY IT HAS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WHEN
WE HAVE A CORE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO.
FILE ITEM. EIGHT A. B. ONE FOUR
SEVEN MR FRAZIER. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR COLLEAGUES
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES RIPPLE RIPPLE RELY
ON DIRECT SERVICE STAFF FOR
CARE. FOR SUPERVISION TRAINING
AND SUPPORT TO MAKE COMMUNITY
LIVING POSSIBLE TODAY THE
TURNOVER RATE OF DIRECT SERVICE
STAFF IS FAR TOO HIGH DUE TO
THE LOW WAGES THEY ARE PAID.
FOR THIS CRITICAL WORK.
PROFESSIONALIZATION OF THIS
WORKFORCE THROUGH OPPORTUNITIES
OF ENHANCED TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION WILL NOT ONLY.
ENHANCE PROVIDER RETENTION. BUT
ALSO WILL CREATE A PATHWAY. FOR
UPWARD CAREER MOVEMENT. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WILL GIVE
THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY TO RECORD
BY REQUIRING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
DEVELOP A MODEL CURRICULUM FOR
A CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
PROVIDERS OF CARE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THAT WILL BE
OFFERED AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IN THEIR CAMPUSES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL WOULD
HAVE WITH ME TODAY AND SUPPORT
STEVE MILLER CONSULTANT OF LOS
ANGELES CO COALITION OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND WHEN DEPLORED
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BAYBERRY
INCORPORATED NONPROFIT AGENCY
THAT OFFERS SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES AND RESIDENTIAL
SUPPORTS TO PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER-
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE FIRST
LEAD WITNESS- TO CALLING FOR A.
B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY IS MISTER
STEVE MILLER. CONSULTANT FOR
THE L. A. COALITION OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS MR MILLER PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS STEVE MILLER
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COALITION OF SERVICE PROVIDERS.
THERE IS A BODY OF EVIDENCE
BASED BEST PRACTICES PROVEN TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN ASSISTING
ADULTS WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL. TO LEARN CAR
FIELD THEY NEED TO REACH THEIR
GOALS COMPETITIVE EMPLOYMENT
AND A HIGH QUALITY YOUR LIFE.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE BEST
PRACTICE SKILLS ARE NOT WIDELY
AVAILABLE TO THE PERSONNEL
WORKING IN THE FIELD DELIVERING
DIRECT INSTRUCTION AND SUPPORT
TO PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES. THIS IS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA LACKS A PROFIT WITH
THE DEMAND WE DELIVER THIS
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL SET TO
DIRECT SUPPORT WORKFORCE
PROVIDED SPECIAL SERVICE.
RESULTS OF THE TRAINING GAPS
ARE EVIDENT CALIFORNIA'S POOR
RECORD OF EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
LEVEL LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION
RATE UNDER 20% THIS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE FOR A STATE
COMMITTED TO THE POLICY COULD
PLAN THE FIRST. REALLY
TECHNICAL THE POINT MINUTE
COMMUNITY LIVING SERIOUSLY WE
MUST DEVELOP THE MEANS TO PUT
THESE TRIED AND TRUE SUPPORT
TOOL IN THE HANDS OF THE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS WE EMPLOY
TO GET THE JOB DONE. AND
COMPENSATE THEM SUFFICIENTLY TO
ALLOW THEM TO REMAIN IN THESE
IMPORTANT POSITION. A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BASED TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WITH A
COMMENSURATE WAGE FOR
CERTIFICATE HOLDERS WOULD BE AN
EXCELLENT. SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MILLER. AT T. MODERN THE
SET LEAD WITH TOOK- IT FOR A.
B. FOR SEP. IS MISSING. LORDY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
BAYBERRY INCORPORATED THIS
CLARITY PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DATA
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I AM
A DEPLORED EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE VERY. SPECIALIZING IN
RIGHTFULLY ACKNOWLEDGING DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS AS LONG
OVERDUE CURRENTLY THE US
CONGRESS HAS INTRODUCED HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIX ZERO FOUR FIVE
AND SENATE BILL THREE THREE SIX
NINE CALLS REQUIRING THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO ASSIGN
THE STANDARD OCCUPATIONAL
CLASSIFICATION. SPECIFICALLY
FOR GSP BABY FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THESE EFFORTS
IN ORDER TO EFFICIENTLY
ESTABLISHMENT MUCH
COMPREHENSIVE CURRICULUM
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WE MUST CONSIDER. THE
FOLLOWING THREE THREE POINTS.
SH ONE TO SERVE REGIONAL IN PDF
NOTHING IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
LEGISLATORS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ENSURE PERSON
CENTRED IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORIENTATION TO THE CURRICULUM.
TO THE MAJORITY OF DSPS ARE
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO
HOLD TWO JOBS OR SINGLE PARENTS
AND ON THAT ACCOUNT THEREFORE
TO ENSURE ADEQUATE MOMENT BOTH
IN PERSON AND ONLINE CLASS
OPTIONS FOR THIS CURRICULUM.
FOR CRITICAL REVIEWS OF
ATTENDING AND LAST YEAR WE
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON INCREASED
TRAINING MUST RESULT IN HIGHER
COMPENSATION TO DSPS.
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
CURRENT AND SO SHE'S RIGHT
STUDY FINDINGS INFORMING US OF
THE SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERFUNDED
SYSTEM STATEWIDE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THE
MYSTERY WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. SO YOU KNOW
WHEN THIS IS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OR ANY TWEETERS WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON
THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR-
SUPPORT FOR AV ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN OR FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. BEGIN SUPPORT FOR A. B.
ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. WE'LL GO FIRST IN
LINE OF NINETY EIGHT NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A
LINE OF ONE SIXTY NINE ONE SIX
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THERESA ANDERSON WITH THE ARK
AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT. WE
DO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL LINE IN
Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FOUR NINE
ONE SIXTY TWO ONE SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI AND MY NAME'S
KATHLEEN SAYING AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. MR MATTER DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
OPPOSITION OR EIGHTY ONE OR.
ONE SEVEN. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE
IN Q. IT'LL BE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE HAVE CLIMBED. ONE
SIXTY SEVEN. THEY'RE NOT QUITE
AVAILABLE ONE MOMENT.
FOR BUT
THE LINE IS FOR SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR- WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO THE TWEETERS FOR A BEFORE
TAX SEVENTEEN WEEK WE CAN HEAR
THAT ONE. OKAY THANK YOU WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SIX SEVEN ONE
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH I'M MAD I'M I'M A MEMBER
OF ALL AGES. TOM ASPECTS OF MY
LIFE. JUNE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
SEVEN THE ISSUE MR MODERATOR IF
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU LIKE THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN THIS PRESS ONE ZERO.
TURN ON LINES IN Q. ANY
WITNESSES- THAT OUR TWEETERS.
YOUR POSITION IS CLEANER FOR A.
B. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN ME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE ONE
ZERO YOUR POSITION IS BETWEEN-
FOR A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU THERE NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. GO
AHEAD. YES I'D JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE OFFER FOR AND THIS IS
REALLY- THOUGHTFUL AND NEEDED
BILL- MY WORK AS A SPECIAL
NEEDS ADVOCATE- I'VE LEARNED
THAT WHETHER YOU ARE A YOUNG
MOM OF A CHILD. WITH DOWN
SYNDROME. I'M LOOKING FOR CHILD
CARE- HAVING THAT HAVING THIS
PROGRAM HAVING- EIGHT REALLY
LOOKING AT DEVELOPING THE WORK
FORCE- IS IMPORTANT FOR YOU FOR
YOUNG MOMS IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT.
FOR OLDER PARENTS- WHO HAVE A
CHILD ON THE AUTISM SPECTRUM
THEY'RE ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT
THEIR CHILD IS BEING TAKEN CARE
OF FOR THEIR ADULT CHILD IS
BEING TAKEN CARE OF. OR IF
YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL- WHO HAS
AUTISM DOWN SYNDROME OR ANY
OTHER DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
I'M KNOWING THAT THE PERSON
THAT- IS THERE FOR YOU DURING
YOUR DAY- HAS THE SKILLS TO
MEET YOUR CHALLENGES. AND BE A
PART OF YOUR SUCCESSES AND HELP
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES IS VITAL
FOR OUR SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNITY
I'M SORRY APOLOGY ON THIS BILL
I WOULD LOVE. TO BE A CO AUTHOR
IF YOU'D HAVE ME THINKING OF.
THIS APPRAISER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. YEAH YES SIR MISTER
CHAIR MISTER CHILD FIRST OF
FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
AS I BROUGHT THIS IDEA TO YOU
YOU ENCOURAGE ME. AND YOU
ENABLED ME TO WORK WITH YOUR
WONDERFUL STAFF WHO BROUGHT
THIS TO FRUITION- WELL WITHOUT
YOU AND YOUR STAFF THIS
WOULD'VE NEVER HAPPENED AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART. FOR MY
COLLEAGUE WHO JUST MADE
STATEMENTS YOU HAD ME AT HELLO
I LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU. ON THIS WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED IN
CALIFORNIA WE MORE CHAMPIONS IN
SACRAMENTO. AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DIG DEEP AND WORK HARD ALSO-
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE. THANK YOU AND I WOULD
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL. FORWARD I
KNOW. HOW MUCH- THE DISABILITY
THE **** MENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY MEANS TO YOU. AND ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE IN
THE YEARS THAT YOU'VE BEEN
HERE- I AGREE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY DESERVES THE BEST
SUPPORT THAT WE CAN GIVE THEM.
THE TRANSITION FOR STATE RUN
CARE TO COMMUNITY LEVEL CARE
REQUIRES NEW LEVELS OF TRAINING
AND EDUCATION FOR PROVIDERS.
MOVING FORWARD I KNOW THAT YOUR
STAFF WILL CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACADEMIC
SENATE TO IDENTIFY THE BEST WAY
TO DEVELOP THIS PROGRAM. MY
RECOMMENDATION ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM IS DO PASS AND AGAIN
THANK YOU MR FRAZIER FOR BIT
BRING THIS BILL FOR. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES. THE
NEXT BILL AND FILE ITEM ORDER
IS A. B. THREE SIX SEVEN FIVE
ITEM NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA. THE MESSAGE PRESS ZERO
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GOING TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WERE WORKING WITH DENTAL
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE AND I
RECOMMEND THAT AMENDMENT. AB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN IS THAT IN
THE NATION BY REQUIRING ALL
SCHOOLS MAINTAINING GRADES SIX
THROUGH TWELVE. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES COLLEGE STATE
UNIVERSITIES YOU SEE IN ANY
PUBLIC AGENCY OF BUILDING TO
PROVIDE FREE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS. FOR ANYONE WHO NEEDS
THESE PRODUCTS I KNOW THAT TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE THERE'S
NOTHING WORSE THAN MOTHER
NATURE. AND OUR BIOLOGY
SURPRISING NOTHING HAVING TO
SCRAMBLE TO DEAL WITH- OUR
PERIODS RANDOMLY OR NOT HAVING
ACCESS OR BEING ABLE TO AFFORD
THEM. AND SO THIS WILL SIMPLY
TRYING TO REMOVE A BARRIER TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
MENSTRUATE. ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO BE PART OF A
PRODUCTIVE PART OF THEIR- IS
WHETHER IT'S A LEARNING
<c.red>NSTITUTION WORK OR JUST</c>
ANYTHING ELSE THEY'RE DOING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS. ON THE CALL FOR A. B.
THREE SEVEN THREE SIX SEVEN. IS
OUR DEAN BLOOM. A UC DAVIS
STUDENT AND CO FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE TH FOR FREE THE
PERIOD. AS LONG IF I'M
PRONOUNCING YOUR NAME CORRECTLY
IF I'M NOT PLEASE FORGIVE ME. A
PLEASE FOR- PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. HI GUESS I'M OUT
IN THE- REPRESENTING THREE THAT
HERE YET A STUDENT COALITION
CHAMPIONING THE SPELL AND
RECORD AND- HARMONY IN THE
STATE. WE STARTED AS A SMALL
GROUP OF STUDENTS THAT QUICKLY
GREW INTO A COLLECTION AS WE
CONNECTED WITH OTHERS ACROSS
THE STATE. MR THREE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS IN BATHROOMS FOR
YEARS. EIGHTY THREE SIX SEVEN
WOULD UNIFY THIS AFTER THAT
UNDER WAY I THINK EIGHTEEN
UNIVERSITIES HAVE ALREADY
PROVIDED PRODUCTS AND SOME OR
ALL OF THEIR CAPTORS. IN BOTH
THE YOUTH AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DEFINITIONS OF BASIC NEEDS
INCLUDE MENSTRUAL HYGIENE WE
CAN MAKE COST SAVINGS BY
ELIMINATING THE LOCKING
PRODUCTIVITY AND EXTRACTION
TIME THAT COMES FROM MISSING
CLASS OR WORK TO TRACK DOWN AN
ADDITIONAL PRODUCTS AND ALSO
ELIMINATE THE HAPPY MAINTENANCE
COSTS OF QUINN OPERATE IN
MITCHELL PARK. SENSORS WHICH
OTHERWISE RESULT IN A NET LOSS.
FINALLY WE CAN APPRECIATE THE
ACTIVISTS OF THIS POLICY BASED
ON THE STATE CAPITOL BUILDING
YOU ARE IN WHICH HAD
PREMENSTRUAL PIPE IN EVERY
WOMAN'S BATHROOM. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS RESPECTFULLY AFTER
RECEIVE THE SAME BASIC SERVICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
LEAD WOULD IS- MON POWER. A UC
SANTA SCHOOL AND- OF DOTS. DOT
STAFF. IS POWER PLEASE PROCEED
YOU'RE A RED. HI WHAT A
CORRECTION I AM NOT YOU DON'T
HAVE A STOCK NUMBER HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME IS MONA POWELL
AND SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS WORKED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION AT UC SAN
DIEGO FOR THE LAST THIRTEEN
YEARS. CURRENTLY SERVING AS
LONG AS AN ENGAGEMENT MANAGER
FOR THE CAMPUS. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS ISSUE IS
NOT ISOLATED STUDENTS THREE
YEARS AGO I WAS DIAGNOSED AND I
HAD UNDIAGNOSED FIBROIDS WHICH
CAUSED ME TO BLEED HEAVILY AND
UNEXPECTEDLY BETWEEN PERIODS. I
AM A ONE DAY IN PARTICULAR WHEN
THE BLEEDING WHAT'S SO BAD I
HAD USED ALL THE PRODUCTS I HAD
WITH ME AND HAD TO ASK STUDENTS
IN THE BATHROOM. WHO LOOKED AT
ME WITH AN E. AT THE RUMMAGE
THROUGH THEIR BACKPACKS WITH NO
LUCK I CRIED SILENTLY IN THE
STALL AND I HEARD THE MAID YOU
WOULD SPOIL THE PAPER IN MY
UNDERWEAR SO I COULD GET TO MY
NEXT MEETING. THIS EXPERIENCE
EXPIRED INSPIRED ME TO ADVOCATE
AND BUILD A SOLUTION TO MAKE
PRODUCTS AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH EDUCATION MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO THAT OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WOULD NOT HAVE TO
GO THROUGH WHAT I WENT THROUGH
AND I LOADED AB THREE SIXTY
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD BE AN
IMPACTFUL FIRST UP. IN TREATING
A LARGE POPULATION WHO LEARN
AND CONTRIBUTE TO A CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION. WITH DIGNITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
THE- COMMENT. SEE NOTE
WITNESSES IN THE BACK AND SO.
NOR ANY WITNESS IN THE OF THE
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION- ANY
TWEETERS. WE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A. B. THREE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OUR FIRST
WILL COME FROM TE LINE AT ONE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU BRIAN
SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE IN SUPPORT. WE'LL GO
TO LINE. ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS LAUREN I
THAT YES THAT MENU ON BEHALF OF
CREDIT FOR THAT CALIFORNIA
LATINAS FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF EIGHTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN AND
INSTRUCT THE PORT. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ALAN FOUNDED ON A
SERVICE EXTERNAL BIKES
PRESIDENT AT UC IRVINE NINE
HEARING STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT. NINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN POSSIBLY HAVE
YOUR MEAT BUT NOT. MOVING TO
THE NEXT PHOTO LINE. ONE MOMENT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAPPING
DOWN OFTEN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AT. EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
SEVEN. AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO
LINE EIGHTY NINE LINE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BOB THIS IS BY SEAN
WITH THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING ONE OF EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSS
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BURNS
STRONG SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR WE COULD GO TO A
POSITION NOW. OKAY AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE NINE ZERO. IN ONE
MOMENT WE DID HAVE QUITE A FEW
QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT SO WE WILL
GET INTO THE ONES THAT ARE
KILLING UP NOW. IF YOU HAVE
QUEUED UP FOR SUPPORT FOR A. B.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN YOU CAN PRESS
ONE ZERO TO REMOVE YOURSELF. SO
FAR WE HAVE NOT HAD ANYONE
QUEUE UP IN OPPOSITION. THIS
MATTER DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
THAT ARE CLEANERS. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP AS A TWEENER
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I OF KNOWING
QUEUING UP FOR- TWEENER. WE'LL
GO TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR- C. QUESTIONS ARE
MR WOULD YOU LIKE TO. AT ONE
THINK THE WITNESS FOR TEST ON
BEHALF- AND. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I WILL. THANK YOU
GARCIA FOR YOUR WORK. AND GET
TO ADVOCATE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS ARE MET.
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE STEPS
THAT YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE ARE
TAKING TO ACCOMMODATE STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS. ON CAMPUS TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS CAN
CONTINUE WITH THEIR EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF ON THE AMENDMENTS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. WHICH I AM TODAY THE
MOTION WILL BE- DO PASS- AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WHEN
WE HAVE. A FOUR. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA. WE HAVE A QUORUM OKAY.
IF- SECRETARY YOU'D LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL. MEDINA PRESIDENT
MEDINA HERE CHARLIE HERE CHOICE
HERE ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM HERE
GABRIEL- WHEN KYLIE LEVINE
LEVINE HERE HELLO. LOW HERE
RUBIO. REALLY OUT HERE SANTIAGO
FELLA. VALIDUS HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CORE. CAN I
GET A MOTION ON THIS BILL. MOVE
BY. MR LOWE SECOND BY THIS
RUBIO OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
I MAYBE NOT HIGH CHILE NOT
PUTTING CHINA NOT VOTING A
ROMULAN. BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL-
WHEN KYLIE LEVIN LEVIN HI LO
HELLO I RUBIO. RUBIO I SANTIAGO
THE LDS WELL THERE IS I. SIX
ZERO ON CALL. SIX ZERO WE WILL
KEEP THE BILL ON CALL. THE NEXT
BILLING FILE ORDER TO BE HEARD
IS A. B. NINETY NINE FILE ITEM
TEN. NOT SURE THAT MR WYNN IS
HERE SO WE WILL THEN GO TO THE
NEXT FILE ITEM BUILD. AND THAT
IS A B. ELEVEN EIGHTEEN FILE
ITEM ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW. YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CARING COLLEAGUE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
WHICH WOULD HELP SHED LIGHT ON
THE INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL AID
PRACTICES OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. AND ON THE JOB
AND SPENDING PRACTICES OF
CALIFORNIA'S WEALTHIEST
INSTITUTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW- THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES. I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE IN THE IN THE BACK OF
THE CHAMBER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OR ANY LINK BETWEEN-
A MOVIE TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON
THE PHONE OR- IN THE QUEUE. AND
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE ONE TOO IN ORDER TO
GET IN THEIR INFORMATION. WE'RE
GOING TO LINE UP TO A HUNDRED
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. RIGHT AND
WRONG WITH THE AND WITH THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS AND WE SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF THE CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM AND SUPPORT
EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE. THANK YOU.
FOR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANYWHERE WITH. WE HAVE
NO OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
THAT ARE TWEETERS. AND IF YOU
ARE A TWEENER PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I
APOLOGIZE THEY'RE QUEUING UP
FOR DIFFERENT- THE- TONIGHT WE
HAVE NO ONE TO YOU FOR TWO
YEARS NO NO TWEETERS MR MODERN.
CORRECT THEY WERE QUEUING UP-
AT THE WRONG TIME THANK YOU-
WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE THEN
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THE
COMMITTEE- MR CARTER CHOICE. AS
A MEMBER OF LOCAL I- SEE- NOW
SOME MERIT SEE HERE INCLUDE
INCREASING THE TRANSPARENCY ON
THEIR FINANCIAL- SITUATION IS-
HOWEVER WHEN YOU REQUIRE AT
THIS- FINANCIAL AID REPORTS- TO
BE MANDATED OF IDEAS SO- BILL
OR TO THE PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES SO. WITH THAT DATA YOU
HAVE COLLECTED WHAT IS YOUR-
PLAN WHAT. TO DO WITH THAT
THOSE THOSE DATA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS YOU KNOW- BECAUSE
THIS IS TAX SUBSIDIZED AND
THERE'S PUBLIC TAXPAYER SUPPORT
FOR THIS WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THESE INDICTMENTS ARE GOING FOR
THE INTENDED PURPOSE IS TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S DIRECTLY GOING
TO THE STUDENTS. AS YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MANY ENDOWMENTS THAT
HAVE GROWN TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND CONTINUES THE DUDE
IS- AND THAT TRAJECTORY AND SO
WE WANT TO HELP INSURE THAT IS
GOING FOR ITS INTENDED PURPOSE.
SO DOES THAT MEAN THAT- YOU
NATURALLY YOU MAY. REQUIRE OR
EVEN NONPROFIT PRIVATE
COLLEGES- WHEN THEY HAVE- IT
ENOUGH FOR EXCEEDING CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF WEIGHT AND ALMOST SO
FOR THEM TO SPEND DOWN AND UP-
IN PROVIDING FINANCIAL AID TO
STUDENTS. I THINK THE INTENDED
PURPOSE TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE GOING DIRECTLY TO
THOSE INTENDED PURPOSES FOR
THOSE STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY AND
THAT WE NEED TO SHED LIGHT ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE WORK WITH
INSTITUTIONS BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE TO ENSURE THAT THAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING. OKAY I- SEE
YEAH. THIS IS- YEAH THEY HAVE
GOOD TASTE GOOD SIZE SO IT IS
SYSTEM SOME SCHOOLS- HAVE
ACCUMULATED A PIANIST AS YOU
HAVE SEEN MY SHOWN IN THE DATA
SEVERAL HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
IN COLLEGES HAVE ACCUMULATED
AND- WHAT THEY WILL DO- IN THE
ENCOURAGING THEM OR MAKING THEM
TO SPEND PEOPLE'S MONEY FOR
FINANCIAL AID THAT IS SO GOOD I
THINK- NTEND TO BUT- PRIVATE
COLLEGES. WHEN THE STATE
DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY DIRECT AID
TO THE SCHOOL EVEN SO SOON SO
MAY BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR A
GRANT- I MEAN IT COULD BE-
INDIVIDUAL ACADEMIC FREEDOM-
THEY MAY HAVE A CERTAIN PLANS
FOR THE FUTURE- THE CAMPUS
EXPANSION OR- BUILDING
PROJECTS- ETCETERA SO- IS- IS-
IS SELECTED INTRUSION INTO THE
ACADEMIC FREEDOM- WHEN WE DON'T
PROVIDE THE- ANY DIRECT AID TO
TWO PRIVATE SCHOOLS. V. DE AS
AS YOU AS YOU MAY UNDERSTAND-
TAXES DOWN WITH DAVID DOMINANCE
THE TAXATION IS PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED AT TAXPAYERS'
BECAUSE THEY RECEIVE THAT
BENEFIT THAT THERE'S COMES
ALONG WITH THE OBLIGATION TO
HAVE GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN
THE PROCESS. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL IS INTENDED TO BE ABLE
TO DO TO ENSURE THAT IN FACT
THAT'S ACTUALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND IF INDEED THAT
YOU ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
TAX BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
ENDOWMENTS IN THE STATE. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR CHOI
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
SELL- IS SINCE SO THE CURRENT
AND DOMINANCE- AND THOSE
RESPONSIBLE INSTITUTIONS MODEL
FOR THE ODOMETER NONPROFITS AND
THE MONEY IS ALREADY TAXED AND
WHEN THE DONOR. GIVE THAT MONEY
R. AS A PARTY IN DAMAGE TO THE
INSTITUTION. NOW THERE'S
ALREADY FEDERAL LAW THAT
REGULATES HOW. IT WOULD BE
AGAINST THE LAW FOR AN
INSTITUTION TO MISAPPROPRIATE
FUNDS. AND AT THE INTENTION OF
THE DONOR SO IS THIS A LITTLE
BIT DUPLICITOUS IF THERE'S
ALREADY A LAWN THERE IS ALREADY
A PROCESS TO MONITOR-
ENDOWMENTS AND NONPROFIT FUNDS.
NO OVER THEM TO THE CONTRARY
IT'S ACTUALLY- TO HELP INSURE
THAT THERE'S GREATER
TRANSPARENCY ON DATA PURPOSE AS
YOU MAY KNOW SOME OF THESE
INDICTMENTS HAVE GROWN. TO
FIFTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AND UP
BILLION DOLLARS- AND THESE
ENDOWMENTS AND WHEN THEY ANSWER
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF IT IS BEING SPENT
DIRECTLY TO THAT OF THEIR
DIRECTIVE PURPOSE IN ADDITION
AS YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS A
FINANCIAL TAX BENEFIT FOR THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE RIGHT
OFFICE FOR THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
BECAUSE WE MADE FOR THEN
DOWNLOADS I THINK THAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY THE QUESTION IS
WHAT'S ENOUGH FOR A DOWN TO
GROW TO FIFTY BILLION TWO
HUNDRED BILLION. IF THAT IT WAS
THE STRUCTURE IN PLACE
SPECIFICALLY WAS TO HELP FORD'S
AGAIN INTENDED PURPOSE SELF
THIS IS A TRANSPARENCY BILL
THIS IS JUST ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THE DATA IS THERE TO BEST
HELP ENSURE THAT- THOSE ATTEND
PURPOSES ARE ACTUALLY OCCURRING
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ESPECIALLY FOR
SMALLER NONPROFITS THAT DON'T
HAVE THOSE BILLION DOLLAR
ENDOWMENTS OR OR DONATIONS-
BECAUSE IT IS SETTING A
PRECEDENT SO THAT'S DEEPLY
CONCERNING TO ME AND- I
UNDERSTAND. YOUR INTENT BUT IT
IS A CONCERN OF MINE. I SEE NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- MISTER LOWE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. ARE
STRICTLY ESCRIBO. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD I BELIEVE THAT
BY PROVIDING TRANSPARENCY ON
THE LARGE ENDOWMENTS AT SOME OF
OUR MOST PRESTIGIOUS COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN OUR STATE
SHOULD ASSIST THE LEGISLATURE
AND BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW INDICTMENTS PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO OUR NEEDIEST
STUDENTS AND IN IN MANY CASES
THOSE STUDENTS ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS. BUT I
ASKED THE OTHER TO PLEASE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MY
COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS AS OUTLINED ON
PAGES THREE AND FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS. DO I HAVE A MOTION.
MR BLOOM. SECOND I MISS RUBIO
THE MOTION BEFORE IS DO PASTOR
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA. MEDINA HI JULY VOTER
CHOICE NOT VOTING A ROMULAN
BLOOM. BLOOM HI GABRIEL- WHEN
KYLIE LEVIN LOW LEVEL II RUBIO
RUBIO HI SANTIAGO BALLADARES.
NO THERE'S NOT VOTING. THAT'S
FOUR ZERO BILLS ON CALL FOUR
ZERO THE BILL IS ON CALL AND
SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS HERE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
THIRTEEN. EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. AND THEN ITEM FOURTEEN
A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. YOUR
CHOICE. OKAY IS IT YOUR VIEW
YES. OKAY WE WERE ABLE TO DO.
FILE I'M THIRTEEN FIRST.
OKAY
ARE YOU PRESENTING- EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU FIVE
FIVE PHONE NUMBER THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO INTRODUCE A. B. NINE
TWENTY SEVEN THE PRACTICAL
SOLUTION TO ELIMINATING THE
SKILLS GAPS AND ENABLING UNDERS
AND REPRESENTED STUDENTS TO
COMPETE IN CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
AND FUTURE ECONOMY. THE MISSION
OF CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INCLUDES PROVIDING ITS
STUDENTS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND
BACKGROUND NECESSARY TO COMPETE
IN TODAY'S ECONOMY. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ACCOUNT FOR
MORE THAN HALF OF THE
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER THE
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
ENTRY LEVEL WORK HAVE
INCREASINGLY INCLUDED
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES. GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN SOLIDIFIED THE
MISSION BY SIGNING SB EIGHT
FIFTY AUTHORIZING THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO ESTABLISH
A STATEWIDE BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE PILOT PROGRAM AT NO MORE
THAN FIFTEEN COLLEGES. THE
CURRENT PROGRAMS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE
PILOTS ARE PORTABLE AND DIVERSE.
IF CURRENT TRENDS PERSIST 38%
OF THE JOBS WILL REQUIRE AT
LEAST A BACHELOR'S DEGREE BY
TWENTY THIRTY. THE POPULATION
IN EDUCATIONAL TRENDS SUGGEST
THAT ONLY 33% OF WORKING ADULTS
IN CALIFORNIA WE'LL HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE BY TWENTY
THIRTY. SHORTFALL OF MORE THAN
ONE MILLION COLLEGE GRADUATES.
THERE'S A CLEAR NEED AND DESIRE
FOR MORE DISTRICTS AND STUDENTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN EXPANDED
PILOT PROGRAM. HOWEVER THE
CURRENT RESTRICTIONS ON THE
NUMBER OF COLLEGES THAT OFFER
BACCALAUREUS HAVE LIMITED
EXPANSION. MOREOVER THE PILOT
SUNSETS ON JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SIX REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATION TO EXTEND THE
PROGRAM. A. B. NINE TWENTY
SEVEN WILL EXTEND THE OPERATION
OF THE STATEWIDE BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE PILOT PROGRAM
INDEFINITELY. MOREOVER THIS
BILL WILL REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE PROGRAM
CONSIST OF FIFTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS AND REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
SEEKING APPROVAL TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE OF UNMET WORKFORCE
NEEDS. THIS WILL ALLOW UP TO
THIRTY PROGRAMS A YEAR. FINALLY
A. B. NINE TWENTY SEVEN WILL
MANDATE THAT THE CHANCELLOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COLLEGES CONSULT WITH AND SEEK
FEEDBACK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. I
PROPOSE BACCALAUREATE DEGREES
TO AVOID DUPLICATION. FOR
STUDENTS TO COMPETE IN TODAY'S
ECONOMY IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
SEIZE ON THIS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AND EXPAND THE
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PROGRAM
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CHANCELLOR CONSTANCE CARROLL
FROM THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT VASSY VARGAS
GRADUATE OF THE WEST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE DENTAL. HYGIENE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU I AM A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. THE
TWENTY NINE ERROR- AT THE SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THERE ARE TWO POINTS
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE.
FOLLOWING A HEARTFELT THANK YOU
TO CHAIRMAN DANA FOR HIS
SUPPORT SITE IN OFFERING THIS
BILL. FIRST THE BILL ADDRESSES
THE FACT THAT MANY EMPLOYERS
AND JOBS THAT USED TO REQUIRE
AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE NOW
PREFERRED THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE
OR REQUIRED THE BACHELOR'S
DEGREE WHICH THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES DO NOT OFFER IN
THESE WORK FORCE FIELD- AND
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT AND WE
HAVE ENSURED THAT THERE WILL BE
NO DUPLICATION OF PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY PROGRAM. IN THIS
EXPANSION. SECOND THE EXISTING
PILOT PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
RESOUNDING SUCCESS. IT MAKES
SENSE IT'S A PORTABLE ANTENNA
AND LESS THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. EIGHTY SIX IT
IS ACCEPTABLE- FOUR TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND STUDENTS
WHO WOULD SEEK ADVANCEMENT-
IT'S DIVERSE IN ITS SERVICE
POPULATION OVER 60% OF THE
STUDENTS IN THE PILOTS ARE
STUDENTS OF COLOR. 85% THAT JOB
THE AVERAGE SALARY INCREASE IS
THE RESULT OF THE STUDENTS
GRADUATING IN TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS. AN IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA NINETY FOUR PERCENT.
OF THE GRADUATES REMAIN IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL FOR CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE AND WE URGE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU THAT
MUST MEAN- DOCTOR CAROL OF
MOVING ON TO SECOND LEAD WITH
NEWS. ACCORDING IN IS. I'M
ACTUALLY- VARGAS A GRADUATE OF
THE WEST LOS ANGELES OF
COLLEGES DISTRICT- ARJUN
PROGRAM WHENEVER YOU ARE REAY
MISS VARGAS GO AHEAD. OKAY
HELLO MY NAME IS ABOUT THE
BARGAIN I AM A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE GRADUATE FROM THE WEST
LOS ANGELES DENTAL HYGIENE
PROGRAM BUT THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN COMING FROM A LARGE
HISPANIC FARM MY PARENTS COULD
NOT AFFORD TO SEND ME TO
COLLEGE FOR THIS REASON I CHOSE
TO ATTEND A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE DENTAL HYGIENE PROGRAM AT
WESTLEIGH DRAMATICALLY CHANGED
MY LIFE I WENT FROM SERVING
TABLE TWENTY YEARS TO BECOMING
A HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL THE
NEXT YEAR IT WAS ONLY A COUPLE
MONTHS AFTER I OBTAINED MY
DENTAL HYGIENE MY SON. THAT I
WAS ABLE TO ESTABLISH MYSELF IN
AN OFFICE AND BEGIN PRACTICING
MY PROFESSION I AM TRULY
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY BY
POTENTIAL COLLEGES AND AT THE
ONE FIFTY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL CAREER WITHOUT
FINANCIAL BURDEN I ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO CONTINUE
THEIR STUDIES. AND I INFORMED
THEM THAT THEIR AFFORDABLE
PROGRAMS OFFERED THE JUDGE
MICHAEL. KENDALL COLLEGE DENTAL
HYGIENE PROGRAM. I URGE THE
CONTINUE EXPAND PROGRAM TO MAKE
IT. IN PEOPLE'S LIVES. THIRD
AND YOU'RE AT ONE FIFTY CAN
HELP USERS ANYTHING I CANNOT
FACTOR. RECEIVE THE TRAINING I
JUST THEY NEED TO BE AN
EMPLOYMENT. AND LET THEM DREAM
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT. BUT IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MISS
MONGERS. MOVING ON TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS- IDEA ANY
WITNESSES OF STANDING ON THE
FLOOR OR GALLERY- I DON'T SEE
ANYONE NOW WE'RE MOVING INTO-
THE FOUR LINES SO AT&T
MODERATOR. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YOU WILL
NOW MOVE TO SUPPORT FOR A. B.
NINE TWO SEVEN WE'LL GO FIRST
TO LINE ONE TWO EIGHT ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I COULD AFTERNOON CHRISTMAS PH
ON ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND NEED
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE
LINE SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MINDSET YOU
YOU MAY PROCEED YEAH THANK YOU
THIS IS MARK MCDONALD MGI
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY TURN NOT
SENTENCING TELL PERALTA PALO
VERDE AND SAMPOERNA DINO- AND
YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WHAT WE DO
HAVE A FULL FIVE FULL GO TO
LINE TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO OH
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON HOW
HIGHLY TO BE HAPPY AT THE CASE
IN A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS AND THE
COURT THANK YOU. LONGING TO- OH
SIX IS NEXT TO ZERO SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MAN IDEA SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY EVERGREEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE LINE
TWO OH NINE TWO ZERO NINE.
THANK YOU MEMBER ACTUALLY
WALKER ON BEHALF OF MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE AND NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
SEVERAL OTHERS IN Q. BUT I
BELIEVE WE'VE REACHED FIVE.
OKAY MOVING ON TO- ANY-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOUR
POSITION AS OPPOSITION TO AB
NINE TO SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THAT'S ONE ZERO THE
STATE OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
PLEASE. I DON'T HEAR ANYBODY AT
THEN- LET'S MOVE ON TO ANYONE-
TWEETERS. IF YOUR POSITION IS
TWEENER A. B. NINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO IF YOUR
POSITION IS TWEENER. HEARING
NONE BIGGER. WHO WE HAVE ONE
LINE IN QUEUE FOR TWEENER SIR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE OKAY.
PRODUCT
LINE TWO ZERO TWO NINE TWO OH
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HARMON HERE OKAY-
SORRY ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE BUT WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
AT THIS TIME YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE BUILDING TENT AND WORKING
WITH THE BILL'S SPONSOR- ON
AMENDMENTS THAT IF ADOPTED WILL
BE THERE TO TAKE A FORMAL
SUPPORT POSITION. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU FOR THE
TWEENER POSITION. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- NOW MOVING ON TO A
LITTLE I MEAN MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. OKAY MOVED
BY. MOOT MOVED INTO SECOND GEAR.
AND CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING COMMENT. MISTER CHAIR
YOU YOU HAVE A COMMENT HERE FOR
MR RUBIO OR ZERO CORP
CORPORATION THANK YOU YES- IT'S
READING I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE- PRIVATE COLLEGES IN
THE CAL GRANT THE GRANTS ARE-
THERE'S A DISPARITY BETWEEN THE
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES AND THE-
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AROUND BUT
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS AND
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THIS IS
NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW BUT THERE IS A BIG
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE GRANTS.
AWARDED FOR PRIVATE COLLEGES
THAN THERE IS FOR FOUR R. U. C.
THEN C. AS USE AS RUBIO ARE- WE
ON THIS BILL RIGHT NOW. THIS IS
THIS IS THE COMMUNITY CALLED.
THE POST SECONDARY. THE GRAPH
THAT HAPPENED PROGRAM. I'M
SORRY IT MIGHT IT MIGHT SHOW UP
SO I THINK YOU'RE MAYBE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEXT BILL OKAY I'M
SORRY I APOLOGIZE THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY
MOTION WAS MADE BY- MEMBER OF
THE V. AND A SECOND ADVISOR SO.
SOMEONE TELLS- ALL RIGHT THEN
I'LL CLOCK- WOULD YOU PLEASE-
HELLO. YEAH. I FEEL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABILITY TO DO IT YOU KNOW
CLOSING CLOSING REMARKS. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
OKAY. NON MOTION HAS BEEN- NOW
MATE AND- TO PASS IT TO
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATIONS
SUBCOMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI THE DATA HI JOY HI JOY I A
ROMULAN. BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL- WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY
LEVIN LEVIN HI LO. HELLO HI
RUBIO RUBIO I. SANTIAGO THE LDS
THOUGH THERE IS HI. FOR THE
BOAT IS EIGHT ZERO WHAT I WAS
BEFORE I THOUGHT I WAS AFTER
YOU KNOW THE BILLS OUT. OKAY AS
PASTOR EIGHT ZERO AND- OR LET
IT OPEN FOR ANY- MEMBERS- YOU
NEED TO ADD ON. AND HE.
THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON MAKING THIS BILL BETTER
AS LEGISLATIVE LEADERS WE
CANNOT MANAGE WHAT WE CANNOT
MEASURE OUR CURRENT EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEMS EXIST IN SILOS THEY DO
NOT TALK TO EACH OTHER AND THEY
USE INCONSISTENT DEFINITIONS
THIS MEANS THAT POLICY MAKERS
AND RESEARCHERS ARE UNABLE TO
ANSWER BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
STUDENT PROGRESS AND OUTCOMES.
OR CURRENT DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
IS USED MAINLY FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
REPORTING. THIS BILL MARKS A
MEANINGFUL SHIFT IN HOW WE USE
DATA. IT WILL EMPOWER US TO
MAKE BETTER MORE IMPACTFUL
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FUTURE.
BASED ON MORE COMPLETE EVIDENCE
AB NINETY NINE WILL ESTABLISH
THE CALIFORNIA CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM WHICH WILL SECURELY
CONNECTED DATA THAT SCHOOLS
COLLEGES FINANCIAL AID
PROVIDERS. AND EMPLOYERS ARE
READY COLLECT ENABLING POLICY
MAKERS AND THE PUBLIC TO HAVE A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF A STUDENT'S
JOURNEY. THIS BILL IMPROVES
UPON THE RECOMMENDATIONS
CREATED BY A ROBUST. AND CROSS
CUTTING STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN ONGOING
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ENSURED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WILL HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
WHICH WILL HELP GUARANTEE THAT
THE SYSTEM FULFILLS ITS MET
MISSION. AS PUBLIC GOOD AND
PROVIDES- DATA THAT IS
ACTIONABLE FOR BOTH POLICY
MAKER IT'S THE POLICY MAKERS
AND STUDENTS. AMENDMENTS
CLEARLY STATE. THAT THE SYSTEM
IS BUILT AND IT WILL BE BUILT
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
PROCESS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS DR SEUSS AND- JAZZ.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA COMPETES IN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS BEEN
DEEPLY ENGAGED ON THIS ISSUE.
WITH A FOCUS ON HELPING THE
STATE MEET ITS WORKFORCE EQUITY
GOALS. HM REMEMBER ERWIN AT T.
MODERATED THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS IS DOCTOR SUED JEN JESS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA COMPETES. DR JEN
JESS PLEASE PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU
CAPITEC GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
TINA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME I DIDN'T AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA COMPETES
WHERE POLICY RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON THE INTERSECTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION EQUITY IN THE
ECONOMY. CURRENTLY OUR STATE
VERY STATE OFFENSE WORK IN
SILOS HOWEVER THE CHALLENGE OF
CALIFORNIANS FACE ARE NOT
TALENT FROM EACH OTHER
CALIFORNIANS. UNDER SERVED IN
K. TWELVE FACE BARRIERS IN
ACCESSING COLLEGE AND ARE WORSE
OFF AND FIND A GOOD JOB THE
INDIVIDUAL SUFFERS AS DOES THE
STATE AS SUCH WE SUPPORT EIGHTY
NINETY NINE INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN IT'S A
LITTLE FIVE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE CRADLE TO CAREER
WORKGROUP WHICH ENGAGE NO
LONGER PARTICIPATORY PROCESS.
IN DEVELOPING ITS PLAN THIS
PLAN ALLOWS FOR OPEN ACCESS TO
USER FRIENDLY DASHBOARD AND IT
PROVIDES TEACHERS AND STUDENTS
OPERATIONAL TOOL TO SUPPORT
COLLEGE AND CAREER PLANNING.
MOREOVER IT ALLOWS POLICY
MAKERS IT BETTER BE ABLE TO
PINPOINT WHERE CALIFORNIANS
FATHER THE CRACKS HOW THAT
VARIES BY RACE GENDER REGION
INCOME WHY IT HAPPENS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT IT THESE DATA SHOULD BE
THE BEDROCK OF ALL SUBSTANTIVE
EVIDENCE BASED CHANGE AS LONG
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT SEE
NO WITNESSES IN THE BACK AND
OPPOSITION OR IN SUPPORT NOR
ANY TWEETERS WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
STATE YOUR POSITION ON A. B.
NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO AND WE'LL
BEGIN WITH SUPPORT. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
ONE SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JOURNALIST HYSTERICAL YET
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AT THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
THE LINE NINE I'M SORRY IT'S
TWO NINETEEN TWO ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT AVAILABLE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA S.
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
BORDERLINE EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
REMEMBER AND THEN ON THE HALF
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BIG. TOTAL
LIMES SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY
SIX DO YOU HAVE A SUPPORT
POSITION FOR A. B. NINETY NINE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME MY LINE YES
SEVENTY SIX OKAY ONE LITTLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO LINE. TWO FOURTEEN
TWO ONE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YOU
MAY PROCEED. TWO FOURTEEN WE
CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR
POSITION OKAY. SORRY ABOUT
THAT- MY NAME IS GENEVIEVE I
REPRESENT THE EDUCATIONAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION CANNOT
SUPPORT. MR MODERATOR WILL GO
DOWN TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DO YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION
OF OPPOSITION TO AB NINETY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
TWEETERS. YOUR POSITION IS
TWEENER TO EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN A POSITION OF
TWEENER FOR EIGHTEEN NINE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. THERE ARE NO TRAINERS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME SIR. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOT GO TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE. ST
NINE SEVEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. GIVEN THE-
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN PRICES AND
ASSOCIATED LEARNING LOSS THIS
DATA SYSTEM WILL BE CRITICAL IN
TARGETING RESOURCES WHERE THEY
ARE MOST NEEDED TO CLOSE EQUITY
GAPS LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE
USE FROM THAT THAT WE LEARN
FROM THIS IMMENSELY CHALLENGING
YEAR SO THAT WE CAN BUILD BACK
BETTER AND ARE PREPARED TO
RESPOND TO THE NEXT CRISIS THAT
DISRUPTS LEARNING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MR WHEN. WHEN
IT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR. THE CREATION OF A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM WILL
PROVIDE SYNERGY. BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS DATA SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND ENABLE POLICY
MAKERS AND PRACTITIONERS. TO
MAKE DATA INFORMED DECISIONS. I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE. TO IMPROVE UPON
THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND TO MAKE ROOM FOR
POLICY DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS. I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CREATION OF
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM.
AND THE INFORMATION IT CAN
PROVIDE DECISIONS TO CLOSE
EQUITY GAPS. AND IMPROVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
TO HAVE A MOTION I MAKE A
MOTION. MOVED BY DR CHOI SECOND
BY MISTER LEVIN. THE MOTION
BEFORE US IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. BOTTOM SECRETARY V.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I SHINE ON
CHOICE HI A ROMULAN BLOOM.
BLOOM HI GABRIEL- WHEN- WHEN I
KYLIE LEVIN LEVIN I LOW RUBIO.
SANTIAGO VALIDUS ELDERS HI. THE
VOTE IS SIX ZERO SOME CALL- SIX
ZERO THAT BILL IS ON CALL THE
NEXT BILL AND FILE THE ORDER TO
BE HEARD IS A B. SEVENTY FIVE
FILE ITEM SUB FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB SEVENTY FIVE PLACES A
KINDERGARTEN AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SCHOOL BOND. ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BALLOTS. THE
STATE HAS BEEN A STRONG PARTNER
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION. OF K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITIES.
THE STATE BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN
MATCHED BY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND LOCAL BOND FUNDS. THESE
FUNDS ENSURE THAT OUR K. TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES STUDENTS
ARE IN SAFE AND UPDATED
FACILITIES. AND BENEFIT THE
ECONOMY BY GENERATING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS. THE NEED IS
GREAT THE FUNDS FROM THE LAST
BOND APPROVED BY THE VOTERS
AND- BY THE VOTERS PROPOSITION
FIFTY ONE FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
ARE ALREADY DEPLETED THOSE ARE
GONNA. FROM THE K. TWELVE SIDE
OVER TWO BILLION IN
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED BEYOND AVAILABLE
FUNDING. WITH SEVENTY THREE
DISTRICTS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SERVE OVER TWO MILLION
STUDENTS. AND IT HAS RAISED ON
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE
COLLEGES FIVE YEAR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PLAN ESTIMATES A TEN
YEAR NEED A FORTY ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AS YOU ALL
PROBABLY KNOW THE LAST ONE WE
PLACED ON THE BALLOT
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN WAS NOT
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS WHAT A
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVENTY FIVE IS
NOT IDENTICAL TO PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN IT IS DIFFERENT I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO MODIFY THE
PROPOSAL TO GET VOTER SUPPORT.
FACILITY SET THE TONE FOR THE
SCHOOL DAY AND HAVE AN IMPACT
ON STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT I CAN
ATTEST TO THAT AS A TEACHER
TESTED BY TESTIFYING BY PHONE
OR DAVID O'BRIEN WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE A JENNIFER
BAKER REPRESENTATIVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACILITY. COALITION.
THANK YOU MR O'DONNELL. AT T.
MODERATED THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF A-
SEVENTY FIVE. DAVID O'BRIEN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
VICE CHANCELLOR. OF MISTER
BRIAN PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAVID RYAN
THE VICE CHANCELLOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE FAMILY'S ALL SEVENTY
FIVE I WANT TO THANK HIS FAMILY
MEMBER- DONALD LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCED REPRESENTED
THE FAMILY MEMBER REFERENCE. TO
PROVE BY VOTERS THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE NEEDED FUNDS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO CONSTRUCT AND MODERNIZE
EDUCATIONAL FACILITY THESE WILL
BE VITAL FOR A KITCHEN TO
ADDRESS LIFE SAFETY CONCERNS
MODERNIZED FACILITY CAN
CONSTRUCT NEW BUILDINGS. WHICH
ARE ESSENTIAL YOU KNOW THEIR
STUDENTS AND FACULTY BEGIN TO
LOOK FORWARD TO A RETURN TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AS YOU KNOW
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE
THE TOP 1100% OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. INCLUDING
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND WE EDUCATE STUDENTS
IN A RANGE OF PROGRAMS FROM
CAREER EDUCATION TO HIGH NEEDS
FIELDS LIKE CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ENTRANCE FOR PREPARATION. FOR
CELERY ARE DIRE NEED OF REPAIR
AND MAINTENANCE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALOGY DOES KNOW THE
DON THAT FACILITY NEEDS OF THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS THE TWENTY NINE
BILLION AND FORTY TWO BILLION
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. AND SO
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MUCH NEEDED MEASURE AND
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST AND I PUT.
THANK YOU THIS PRIME EIGHTY T.
MODERN THIS LEAD. AND SUPPORT.
IS MR BASS. ADVOCATE FOR.
COLLEGE FACILITY COALITION.
MISS BAKER YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JENNIFER BAKER AND I'M
PLEASED TO BE REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT'S ONLY
COALITION A PROUD SUPPORTER AND
EIGHTY SEVENTY FIVE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE MEASURE WOULD
PROVIDE A VEHICLE TO GARNER
FUNDS FOR THE SUCCESSFUL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROGRAM COUNT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE OVER
THIRTY POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL FACILITY
NEEDS OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
INCLUDING- CLOSE TO NINE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION OVER THIRTEEN AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR
MODERNIZATION AND CLOSE TO
SEVEN AND A HALF. BILLION
DOLLARS IN DEFERRED GAINS.
MAYBE SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
FINALLY EXISTING CAPITAL
OUTLAYS PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE COLLEGES MORE CERTAINTY
IF THEY PLANNED THEIR PROJECT
AMBON POPE FRANCIS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDE HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROJECTS. FIDELITY
EITHER AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT
OF PROVIDING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
EDUCATION AND CAREER TRAINING.
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACILITY COALITION I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT AT SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU BAKER. WILL NOT
GO TO A PUBLIC COMMENT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. AT AT AT LET ME SEE
IF WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THE
MIKE IS ON.
SH.
GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT OF AV SEVENTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION ARE WINNERS IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AT&T MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO STATE YOUR POSITION FOR A.
B. SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE DO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE WILL BEGIN
WITH SUPPORT BEGIN TO STATE
YOUR POSITION FOR A. B. SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. START WITH LINE SEVENTY
ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU SURE MEMBERS MARKEL
DONALD WHICH M. G. R. IF YOU
SEE ON BEHALF OF. THE SAMPLE
KINO POLSKA BOX AND DYSENTERY
SAN FRANCISCO CA- AND YUBA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS ALL
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU. OKAY GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK. NEXT WEEK. NEXT OVER
THE LINE. ONE EIGHTY SIX ONE
EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT'S ON OUR THAT TELL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES THAT THAT. FORGET THE
EIGHTY SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMENT THIS LINE TO
TWELVE TWO ONE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LITTLE DID YOU WORK
HERE'S WHAT YOU NEED TO CALL TO
THE POPCORN AT THIS POINT. ON
THE LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE
FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
INTERNET CAN LET ME HALF OF THE
STUDENT CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE STRONG
SUPPORT. AND MR MODERATOR WILL
NOW GO TO PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
POSITION AS OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. WATCH WHICH. I
THANK MR JOURNAL LINES IN Q. MR
MODERATOR THERE ANY TWEETERS.
IF YOUR POSITION IS TWEENER ON
A. B. SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE QUEUE
UP BY PRESSING ONE BUTTON ZERO
AGAIN TWENER ON EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE ONE ZERO PLEASE. IT'S
THEY'RE NOT ALIGNED IN Q. THANK
YOU GOING TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C. NINE-
IS TO. DESTROY DONALD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AS FOR NOVEL
THANK YOU- THANK YOU- TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
I UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF BOTH
THE K. TWELVE IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD. AS PART OF YOUR
OVERALL DISCUSSION ON BOND
MEASURES TO BE APPROVED THIS
YEAR BY THE MEASURE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AUTHOR SO
I MAY BE ADDED AS A CO OP. YES
ZURCHER THANK YOU. WITH THAT DO
I HAVE A MOTION. BUT MR LEVINE
SECOND. BUT MRS VALLADARES-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA HI CHARLIE.
CHARLIE NOT VOTING A ROMULAN
BLOOM. BLOOM I GABRIEL- WHEN-
AND I HIGHLY LEVIN LEVIN I LOW
LOW I RUBIO. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI HELLO HERE THOUGH THERE IS
HI. THE LOTUS SEVEN ZERO OUT AT
SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
NEXT BILL AND WHILE ITEM ORDER
WHO'S OUT THERE I SEE HERE IS
FILE ITEM. EIGHTEEN MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOLACE MR SELLERS YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR MANY MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
MOTION IN THE SECOND OF THREE-
MEMBER SAY I PRESENT TO SIMPLY
BUILD TWELVE SIXTEEN WHICH WILL
EMPOWER STUDENT VOICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
AND BRING STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER
TO CHART A PATH FOR THE ROLE OF
OUR STUDENT TRUSTEES SOON
TRUSTEES ACT AS A VALUABLE
SOURCE OF STUDENT PERSPECTIVES
DURING BOARD MEETINGS. THEY
HAVE THE SAME GENERAL
RESPONSIBILITIES AS A PUBLICLY
ELECTED TRUSTEES AS THEY ARE
ELECTED BY THE RESPECTIVE
STUDENT BODIES- WITH THAT I DO
HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF
MR CHAIRMAN AND IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO-
MOVE THAT SECTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH DO YOU DO YOU DO YOU HAVE
A THE WITNESSES. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF WITNESSES ON
OKAY GREAT SO WE'LL GO THEN TO-
WE'LL GO MISTER MODERATOR TO
WITNESS- CATHERINE SQUIRE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR STUDENT CENTER.
FOR NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COLLEGES. THE SQUARE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HELLO YOU CAN MAKE YES. OKAY
PERFECT THANK YOU HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME IS CAPTAIN
FIRE ALARM ON THERE TO BE ABLE
TO BECOME SELF TODAY BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE REALITY
IS THAT THE SENATE HAS THE VERY
EXACERBATED RACIAL INCOME AND
OTHER TYPES OF PRE EXISTING
INEQUITIES HI MAKING A FEW
CALLS SIXTEEN CENTRAL AND
EMPOWERING THEIR STUDENTS WITH
A MODEL THAT FACULTY STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE ENJOYED AT
A PARTY AT THIRTY EIGHT SHE IS
A FORMER STUDENT AND I THOUGHT
I OFTEN THOUGHT UNDER TRAINING.
SO CAN I STILL HAVE THE OLD
VERY FEELING THAT NO MATTER HOW
MUCH I SPOKE UP IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR MY WORK TO HAVE
A REAL IMPACT BUT PROVOKE
ACTION CONNECTING WITH OTHER
TROPHIES THEN YOU REALIZE THAT
THIS EXPERIENCE HAVE BECOME
NORMALIZED. WE CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD TO BE COMPLACENT IF YOU
CAN WITHIN SURE THAT IT IS AND
THEY'RE BOTH RECEIVE MATTER
THAT WE ARE TRULY IS IT I'M
TWENTY FIVE OF A. VISION
EXACTLY. WELCOME THIRTY FIRST
STEP IN HOW YOU TO HAPPY REPEAT
THE BURDENS RECORD REAL OF. THE
BEST I WOULD LIKE TO ADD.
REGION EIGHT SO ON A. B. CORP
SIXTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR.
MADE T. MODERATED SECOND
WITNESS. IS ANDREW NICK IN
RIGHT PRESIDENT LET'S JUST
AFFAIRS. FOR THE STUDENTS OKAY.
COMMUNITY THEDICKENS WHEN YOU
ARE READY. I APOLOGIZE MISTER
DON'T SHOW THAT LINE CONNECTED
IF YOU'RE CONNECTED. YOU MAY
PRESS. ONE ZERO. EVERY ROOM WE
MAY HAVE TO MOVE ON. HELLO A
WEEK WE ACTUALLY JUST HAVE ONE
WITNESS. JUST THE ONE WITNESS
OKAY SO WE WILL NOW GO TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE CHAMBER EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION-
TWEETERS WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
EITHER ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR ON IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON A. B. TWELVE
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT'S ONE
ZERO WE'LL BEGIN WITH SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH FIVE
ONE HUNDRED FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HOME OF ON LINE TO THIRTY
SIX TWO THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY TWO THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DISCONNECTED HOME OF
THE LINE SIXTY ONE SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JEFFREY FROM D. AND THE
COLLEGE AND I AM SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTEEN ONE TWO
ONE SIX. THANK YOU WELCOME AND
ALIGNED TO THIRTY FOUR TWO
THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS PRIYA I'M FROM
THE FACILITY AND THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE STUDENT TRUSTEE
AND SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY ONE TWO
ONE SIX. THANK YOU MR NO FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE STATE OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN OPPOSITION ANY TWEETERS. IF
YOU HAVE A POSITION A TWEENER
FOR A. B. TWELVE SIXTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THAT'S ONE ZERO
MODEL FIRST LINE TO THIRTY FIVE
TWO THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
CANADIAN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SEVENTY
THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. NOW WHY WOULD YOU NOT
HAVING A BUSINESS ON THIS BILL
THIS TIME I WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
PROPOSED- IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT THE TEST BECAUSE-
AND I AREN'T TOO SHOULD BILITY
TO MANAGE- EITHER AFFAIRS- WE
ALSO CONTINUE TO SHARE THE
CONCERNS RAISED ME NOW. THAT'S
REALLY DUE TO THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE WHOLE
APPROACH TO THE TRUSTEE-
HOWEVER WE DO THINK THAT THIS
BILL AS AMENDED IS MOVING
FORWARD IN THE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. TOWARD WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR NINE THE SPONSORS OF
THE MEASURE AT THIS BUILDING IS
WORKING. DILIGENTLY TO PROCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO NO NOT
REALLY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY OR COMMENTS. I
WONDER IF FOR. THE AMENDMENTS
WERE ACCEPTED. YES YEAH OKAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS C. NINE
MR SERVICE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT
I'VE HEARD SO WE GIVE STUDENTS
MORE OF A VOICE THANK YOU
PATRICIA THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF TO
CRAFT THE SUGGESTED. AMENDMENTS
AS A FORMER TRUSTEE I SUPPORT
PRESERVING LOCAL AUTHORITY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE EDUCATIONAL
DECISIONS- AND THINK THAT
DECISIONS MADE LOCALLY ARE
BETTER. THAN DECISIONS MADE
HERE. AND WHILE I'M SYMPATHETIC
TO THE STUDENTS DESIRE FOR
EQUITABLE. REPRESENTATION ON
THESE BOARDS I HESITATE TO MAKE
ANY DECISIONS THAT WOULD STRIP
LOCAL GOVERNING BOARD OF THEIR
AUTHORITY. SO I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO READING THE REPORT FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. DID I HAVE
A MOTION. THE MOTION MOTION BY
MR LOWE'S SECOND BY MR BRING.
ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA HI JOY HI JOY
I'D A ROMULAN. AROUND ELY BLOOM.
BLOOM HI GABRIEL- WHEN- WHEN I
KYLIE LEVIN LEVIN I LO LO I
RUBIO SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
DELETERIOUS WELL THERE IS HI.
THAT IS NINE ZERO NINE OUT NINE
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT- SEEING NO
OTHER AUTHORS. WE WILL GO WE
WILL GO TO FILE I DON'T.
FOURTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX- FOURTEEN FIFTEEN YEAH YEAH.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AT LAST
BUT NOT LEAST CHAIRMAN DEAN AND
I ARE PROUD TO PRESENT HIS BILL
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX I REALLY
MONUMENTAL EFFORT THIS YEAR IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE BUDGET
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA DEBT FREE
COLLEGE I ONCE AND FOR ALL YEAH
YOU HEARD ME RIGHT WE CAN MAKE
COLLEGE DEBT FREE IN CALIFORNIA
BY REFORMING OUR CAL GRANT
PROGRAM TO EXPAND ACCESS FOR
THOSE WHO JUST MISSED OUT. AS
WELL AS INCREASE AWARD AMOUNTS
TO COVER THE NON TUITION COSTS
WHICH WE KNOW ARE THE REALITY
OF CALLS TODAY 80% OF COLLEGES
NON TUITION I CALVIN PROGRAM IS
BEEN AND BEEN THE ENVY OF THE
NATION FOR SIX DECADES BUT IT'S
OUT WHO OUTLIVED ITS USEFULNESS
A FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS CURRENTLY GET IT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S BUILT TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT AND NOT TO
BRING PEOPLE IN- IT'S PRIMARILY
GEARED TO STUDENTS EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR. WE KNOW SO MUCH OF
A CALL YOUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
WHO GO TO COLLEGE- MUCH LATER
IN LIFE AND NOT ALWAYS GO AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL AND AGAIN- IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS FOCUS ON THE
TRUE COST OF COLLEGE ATTENDANCE
SO THIS IS ABOUT EXPANDING
COLLEGE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY IN CALIFORNIA-
MAKING COLLEGE DEBT FREE IN
CALIFORNIA AND LET ME TURN OVER
TO CHEER MEDINA. TO GO OVER
SOME. OF THE OTHER POINTS OF
THE LEGISLATION. THANK YOU
MMHM. REMEMBER MCCARTY-
CHAIRMAN MEDINA OUT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADD TO YOUR STATEMENTS
YES THANK YOU. A. B. FOURTEEN.
FIFTY SIX WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING. WILL CONSOLIDATE THE
THREE CAL GRANT AWARDS. INTO A
NEW CADRE TWO. AND A CAL GRANTS
FOR PROGRAMS. CAL GRATITUDE
WILL GUARANTEE AN AXIS AWARD
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WELL CAL GRANT
FOR IT WILL MAINTAIN A TUITION.
FEE AWARD TO STUDENTS ATTAINING
AN ELIGIBLE FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION. A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX WILL REMOVE AGE
LIMITS TIME SINCE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION AND GPA. ELIMINATING
THE NEED FOR THE COMPETITIVE
COD GRANT PROGRAM THIS WILL
OPEN UP I WAS ABILITY FOR
CALLING GRAND AID TO NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS FINALLY A.
B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL
ALIGN STATE AND FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID POLICIES TO
CREATE A MORE COORDINATED
APPROACH TO INVESTMENTS IN
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. I'M
REALLY HONORED TO HAVE WORKED
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS ON TELEGRAPH REFORM IN
PREVIOUS SESSIONS. HOWEVER THE
PANDEMIC AS YOU KNOW HAS
REVEALED THE EXTREME
INEQUALITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
NOTABLY IN OUR SCHOOLS WE'VE
SEEN STUDENTS STRUGGLE WITH THE
COST OF ATTENDANCE. WE AS A
STATE MUST MODERNIZE OUR
APPROACH TO STUDENT AID. BY
REFORMING OUR CALTRANS SYSTEM
NOW CALIFORNIA WILL SUPPORT ITS
DIVERSE STUDENTS AND GRANT THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION. HERE TO
TESTIFY IS J. BREMER FROM THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
CRYSTAL RANGE FROM THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. OKAY
CHAIRPERSON KNOX INDIANA THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THIS IS WE HAVE
ONE YOU SEVEN MINUTES SO THIRTY
ONE THIRTY DROP THIS TIME-
LESS- TRYING TO- PRIMARY LEAD-
WITNESS- FOR A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX- JACO- PRIMER SO WHO
IS THE DIRECTOR FOR GOVERNMENT
AND- EXTERNAL RELATIONS ARE AT
THE- CALIFORNIA EIGHT OF
COMMISSION. AND NOW MISTER
BREMER AND WE. ALREADY PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
MEDINA AND VICE CHILE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AT
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX REFLECTS
WORK THAT IT'S BEEN YEARS IN
THE MAKING TO SIMPLIFY AND
EXPAND THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
INCLUDING A DELIBERATIVE
PROCESS IN WHICH STUDENTS
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND
OTHER EDUCATION ADVOCATES CAME
TOGETHER IN THE CAL GRANT
REFORM WORK REGIONS. PRIOR TO
THE ONSET OF COKE IN NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WERE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS AS HEY
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION WE KNOW
THAT THE POPE AT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND RELATED ECONOMIC
IMPACT HAVE ONLY COMPOUNDED
THAT CHALLENGE. WHEN THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION SURVEYED
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND INCOMING-
RETURNING COLLEGE STUDENTS LAST
YEAR ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. MORE THAN
SEVEN OUT OF TEN INDICATED THAT
THEY OR THEIR FAMILY WHILE SOME
OR ALL OF THEIR INCOME. DUE TO
COPE IN NINETEEN. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD VERY TO
STUDENT ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID
AND MAKE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS. ELIGIBLE FOR A PELL
GRANT JUST IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
APPLICATIONS UNDER THIS NEW
FRAMEWORK. ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MEDINA PARTY. FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BECAUSE AS
WELL AS THEIR CO AUTHOR SENATOR
CONNIE LEYVA AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR PRIMERA- LET ME- TRYING
TO- SECONDLY WITNESS- CRYSTAL
RAINS- WHOSE- CSU STUDENT
TRUSTEE ON CSU BOARD WHAT
TRUSTEES- MR. RAINES RISK PERCY.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KRISTA
RANTS AND I COME TO YOU SIMPLY
THE FOURTH YOUR SEISHI BACON
FOR STUDENT AND AS A PRODUCT OF
THE PUBLIC SYSTEM AND I WAS
TOLD THAT IF I WANT TO ASK YOU
COULD USE I MUST GO TO COLLEGE
RECEIVING HOWEVER HAS BEEN
CRUCIAL TO ACHIEVING MY COLLEGE
EDUCATION. AND HAS ENABLED ME
TO LEAVE AN ABUSIVE HOUSEHOLD
AND ALLOW ME TO HAVE A HEALTHY
WORK IN SCHOOL THAT.
COMPARATIVELY I KNOW STUDENTS
WHO DON'T RECEIVE COVERAGE HAVE
TO WORK FORTY PLUS HOURS A WEEK
NOT ONLY TO PAY TUITION BUT THE
RISING COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA THIS NEW FRAMEWORK
NOT ONLY HELP STUDENTS PAY FOR
TUITION THE INSTITUTIONAL AID
THAT RECOGNIZE THAT STUDENTS
NEED TO EAT AND HAVE A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS AS THEY PURSUE
THEIR DEGREE. PERSONALLY I HAVE
MOVED SIX TIMES IN MY CULTURE
AND I'M CURRENTLY RE APPLYING.
TO CALFRESH TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
SIMPLY I KNOW HOW GREAT.
BECAUSE IT ADDRESSED THE BIG
PROBLEMS THAT STUDENTS FACE
WHEN. GETTING A DEGREE.
FINANCES I'M ABLE TO SEE BEFORE
YOU TODAY BECAUSE THE PELL
GRANT. GRANTING MORTGAGES
FINANCIAL EIGHTEENTH GIVING
STUDENTS WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD COLLEGE A CHANCE TO
BECOME YOUR NEXT DOCTOR. LAWYER
TEACHER. STUDENTS LIKE ME
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION. AND
VOTING IN FAVOR TO REFORM WILL
IMPACT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS. WILL COME TO
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE LESS
COVERED BY K. ARE YOU FOR YOUR
VITAL SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DRESS THE RAIN- WE- NON-
MOVED TO. COMMENT IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE FLOOR IN THE
GALLERY- NOT SEEING ANYONE
STANDING NOW SO MOVE- MOVE ON
TO THE PHONE LINE SO. EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A. B.FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX IN YOUR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO WELL THE FIRST LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- OUR COUNTRYMEN
THEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND DOCUMENTED
HIGHER EDUCATION COALITION.
INSTRUCTOR CORPS AT EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE A LINE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT ONE SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SERRA GARCIA DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AT THE TELECOM
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANKS FOR THE LINE TWO
TWO NINE TWO TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI IS JOHN LEWIS IN
THE ASSISTED IN THE SEARCH OF
THE CREDIT GROWING BECAUSE
BEGINS SUPPORT OF THE OF IS
THAT. ONE OF ON ON LINE TO
EIGHT TO TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE
HABITABLE DOWN WITH WIDENING
GROUP ONE THING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
MANY MORE LINES IN CUBA OR
FIFTH LINE WILL COME FROM ONE
TO FORTY THREE TO FOUR THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT
AVAILABLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION IN SUPPORT.
DIRECTOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO MEET
OPPOSITION YES. PLEASE THANK
YOU THERE'S A STATE YOUR
POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE AB. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. WITH YOUR
PERMISSION ALL THE LINES
BETWEEN- IF YOUR POSITION IS
TWEENER ON A. B. ONE FOUR FIVE
SIX FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT'S
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
AND I DO HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN
Q. B. ONE MOMENT. LINE SIXTY
SEVEN SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TYLER ARE
YOU ARMY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE UC DOES NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL WE
DO WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN
DEMANDED SOME NEVER MCCARTY
FURTHER EFFORTS TO IMPROVE AND
MODERNIZE THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING A COLLABORATIVE PARTNER.
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU. OVER
THE NINE ONE TWENTY NINE ONE
TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTINA
MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CON
CONFERENCE- EXPRESSION IF THE
PORTRAIT AMENDED POSITION- THE
AMENDMENT WE ARE REQUESTING ARE
IN LINE WITH THOSE REQUESTED BY
A. I. IF YOU. HAPPEN TO WORK
MORE WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
NADINE AND MCCARTY ON THAT
THING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
TWO EIGHTEEN TWO ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M NINETY NINE BUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SEVERAL SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION ON THE GALLERY
THANKFUL FOR THE ON GOING
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND THE AUTHOR STAFF. THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT HAVING ACCESS
TO PREDICTABLE RESOURCES FOR
NON TUITION COSTS AND A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR
STUDENTS PERSISTENCE AND
GRADUATION. 75% OF RCS I COULD
BE INTERESTED THE COW GRANT THE
ACCESS AWARD FOR NON TUITION
COSTS. WHICH WOULD NO LONGER
ACCEPT UNDER THE PROPOSED
STRUCTURE BY THE GREATER NUMBER
OF CSU STUDENTS WOULD RECEIVE
TUITION COVERAGE FROM THE DAY
AND INTO THE PUZZLE WE DO HAVE
TO CONTINUE. ENGAGING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S MATTER TODAY. TO
pAND- YOU CAN RECEIVE THE SAME.
NEXT WE KNOW WE'LL GO LINE TWO
SEVENTEEN TO SEVENTEEN OH ONE
OF THE- GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
HISSES FOR THE PAST AND THEN
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES THAT BUCKY
PROGRAM STUDENTS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT IF AMENDED. AND I
BELIEVE OUR FIFTH WINNER WILL
COME FROM NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX GRAVES OF
THE ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK ON THIS- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEN IN POSITION FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR YOU MAY CONTINUE.
OKAY THANK YOU. I'M MOVING ON
TO- NO A COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
MRS MILLER THERE THERE IS QUIET
THANK YOU- TO THE OTHER IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SOME OF THE
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES ARE
CONCERNED. ABOUT THEIR STUDENTS
WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN INADVERTENTLY LEFT
OUT OF THE BILL- AND MAY BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED WITH THE
DECREASED PURPLE PER PUPIL
FUNDING FOR THOSE STUDENTS I'M
A IF YOU COULD OFFER
CLARIFICATION ON THIS IT WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL. YOU ARE
CORRECT THAT- INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES ARE NOT AT THIS. TIME
INCLUDED ON THE- DEPENDENT
CHILDREN PARK- I'VE BEEN IN
DISCUSSION WITH THEM AND- WILL
CONSIDER MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU I WOULD JUST URGE YOU- FOUR
AS STUDENTS ARE PARENTS- THIS
IS NECESSARY RESOURCES- THAT
WOULD HELP THEM- WITH THEIR
DEGREES AND THEIR POSSIBLE I
APPRECIATE THAT CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IF NOT
THE- GERMAN MEDINA- ANY CLOSING
STATEMENT I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION. A MYSTICAL THE-
DO I SEE ANY MOTION TO THE-
WINDED. UP OKAY- OKAY A DOCTOR
OR UMBRELLA MADE A MOTION AND
SECOND. THE MICHELE- OWEN ALL
RIGHT. THE MOTION HAS BEEN MADE
AND US A SECOND DATA- TO PASS
OUT TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
SUBCOMMITTEES SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA HI
JULY. JULY I'D A ROMULAN AROUND
A LOT I BLOOM. BLOOM I'D
GABRIEL. APRIL I- ONE- WHEN I
HIGHLY. HOME LEVIN LEVIN I LOW
HELLO I RUBIO. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI HELLO THERE AS-
WELL THERE IS NOT VOTING. THE
VOTE IS NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT OKAY STILL- IS ALSO A NINE
ZERO. THANK YOU CHAIR. THANK
YOU DOCTOR CHOICE WE JUST MADE
IT ALL WE HAVE WE HAVE ONE MORE
BILL FINAL BILL AND THEN GOT
INTO HIS PAST THE FINAL BILL
ITEM EIGHTEEN AV TWELVE OR I'M
SORRY. ROUND ONE- SLIGHTLY LAST
ONE FILE ITEMS. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BURGESS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING. ME TO
PRESENT A B. FIVE TWENTY FOUR.
WITH REGARD TO OF. LEARNING TO
COLLECT THE CIVIC INFORMATION
FROM CAMPUSES. RECOGNIZE YOUR
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES.
THIS REPORT INSTITUTION TO ONLY
PUBLICIZE INFORMATION COLLECTED
INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT INCIDENTS ON THE
SCHOOL WEBSITE AND DISTRIBUTE
THAT INFORMATION VIA CAMPUS
EMAIL. BECAUSE THESE INCIDENTS
IN GREEK LIFE ORGANIZATIONS CAN
HAVE SEVERE IMPACTS ON STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES STUDENTS
SHOULD HAVE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE ORGANIZATIONS THEY
PLAN ON JOINING. THIS BURNING
CHRISTIANS CURRENCY WHICH IS A
KEY PIECE TO KEEPING OUR
STUDENTS SAFE WITH ME TODAY
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AS ALICE GUY
IN. THE LAB OF THE LOGOS WITH
STUDENTS AGAINST SEXUAL SO.
THANK YOU AND- AT T. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE- ALLOW THE
WITNESS TO BEGIN. THE FIRST
LEAD WITNESSES MISTER MISS
FILIPPO VIA LOBOS POLICY
ANALYST FOR STUDENTS AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT MISS VIA LOBOS
IF YOU ARE READY YOU MAY
PROCEED. HELLO MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE I'M A STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA THE POLICY
ANALYST OF STUDENTS AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND A SURVIVOR
OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN THE SOUTH
COUNTRY SURVEY IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY WE FOUND THE ASIDE FROM
UCSC CAMPUS OF THE WHOLE
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES
WERE THE MOST REPORTED LOCATION
FOR INSTANCES OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. OF SURVEY RESPONDENTS
EIGHTY FOUR STUDENTS REPORTED
BEING SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE STUDENTS
REPORTED BEING SEXUALLY
HARASSED A FRATERNITY CHAPTER
HOUSES I CAN AFFIRM THE
ALARMING RATE FOR MY LIVED
EXPERIENCE AT UCSB I CROSS THE
STREET FROM A BLOCK OF
FRATERNITY HOUSES YEAH I DON'T
KNOW WHICH LOCATION BECAUSE THE
THREAT TO MY SAFETY. EVERY YEAR
THEY'RE SCATTERED REPORTS OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE THAT COULD TURN
THESE AND RUMORS OF WHICH
HOUSES WELCOME PREDATORY
BEHAVIOR BUT THERE CONTINUES TO
BE LIMITED EFFORT ACTUALLY
INFORM STUDENTS SO WE CAN MAKE
SAFE DECISIONS ABOUT HER BODY.
OTHER SURVIVORS I KNOW THE
CONSEQUENCES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
FAR TOO WELL AND SO TODAY I ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR IN AN EFFORT TO
BRING TRANSPARENCY AND
COMPLACENCY AROUND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MS VIA LOBOS AT&T MODERATOR THE
SECOND LEAD WITNESS CALLING IN
IS A LEAH'S GUY VICE PRESIDENT
OF STUDENTS AGAINST SEXUAL
ASSAULT. THIS. GUY YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DEAN AT
I'M NOT YOU'RE UNDER. STUDENT
YOU BE IN WOULD BE EASY FOR A
ACTIVE BE REPRESENTING ALL YOU
GET BE UNDER. UATE SHARE FOR
THE EASY IN THIS. WHICH RECORDS
ALL YOU KEEP. AND THE BIKE.
STAND AGAINST ASSAULT THE CODE.
OF THE PLEDGED. ON BEHALF OF
YOUR TEETH IN THE BACK SEAT GET
BEATEN UP AND HERE ARE
COMMITTED TO THEIR I. ABOUT.
SEXUAL BANTER THE PREVALENT
ISSUE IN EVERY COLLEGE
COMMUNITY BUT BECOME EVEN
LARGER CONCERN THE GREEK LIFE
COMMUNITY AT THE RATE THERE
STAGGERING. ACCORDING TO STUDY
FOR TWENTY NUMBERS ARE THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT
SEXUAL VIOLENCE BUT THEY'RE NON
CONTRACTED COUNTERPART. RIGHT
THERE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECTED ME AND I
BELIEVE THAT BOTH POSSIBILITIES
DR THERE'S NOT LIKE MINE. THE
FIRST WEEK OF MY FRESHMAN YEAR
ESP I WAS DRUGGED AND ASSAULTED
AND LEFT FOR DEAD. I DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT LOCATIONS THAT
ORGANIZED ORGANIZATION PER SE
FOR THE NEW STUDENT. AND MAYBE
IF THE THOUGHT OF BEEN AN
ACTIVE BEFORE I WOULD HAVE.
NOTHING WILL CHANGE WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME BUT YOU HAVE THE
POWER TO POSSIBLY CHANGE WHAT
HAPPENS TO OTHERS. PLEASE USE
THAT POWER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS GUY WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. SEE NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OR TWEENER. WE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONES. AT&T
MODERATOR. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE OR- IN THE QUEUE TAKE.
THANK YOU MUCH TO SAY YEARS OF
FOR A TWO. I'M SORRY FIVE TO
FOUR THIRTY PM TO P. YOU PRESS
ONE OF THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
THAT'S ONES PLEASE. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE A NINE EIGHT NINE
ALAINA OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
PART ON THE DECEASED LOOK
LOCATION OF THE TESTIMONIAL- WE
ARE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF
THE LEGISLATION. THANK NEXT WE
HAVE A LINE ONE TWENTY ONE ONE
TWO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALAN AT
THAT ON A SERVICE EXTERNALIZED
PRESIDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE NINE HEARING
STRONG SUPPORT. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO TWO NINE TWO TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
JOSH LEWIS FROM UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. YOU SPOKE A MOMENT
THAT PROBABLY BECAUSE BOXES AT
THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU MR NOT FOR THE LINES
IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THE STATE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN MASS OPPOSITION TO
AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ANY TWEETERS MR
MODERATOR. IF YOUR POSITION IS
TWEENER ON A. B. FIVE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AGAIN TWEENER ON A. B.
FIVE TO FOUR. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. NO TWEETERS.
ALL RIGHT THIS IS THIS IS OUR
LAST BILL- BEFORE WE END I WANT
TO THANK THE MODERATOR FOR IS
EXTREMELY- EFFICIENT JOB OF
GETTING OUR- HEARING THROUGH SO
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR FOR ALL
YOUR HELP. TODAY ANY ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. NINE. MR
RODRIGUEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE OUR BACKGROUNDS RIVAL
THANK YOU I THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS CONCEPT
FORWARD AND FOR THE WORK OF
YOUR STAFF THAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH MY COMMITTEE SAT
TRANSPARENCY ALLOWS FOR
INFORMED DECISION MAKING
HIGHLIGHTING GOOD ACTORS AND
BAD ACTORS ALIKE I TRUST THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND IRON
OUT ANY COMPLEXITIES MOVING
FORWARD I'M HAPPY HAPPY TO GIVE
THIS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
OF THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO
PASS IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MADAM SECRETARY
CALLED THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA.
CHILE CHILE I ROMULUS. AROUND
ELY BLOOM. BLOOM HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL I- WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY.
KYLIE NOT VOTING LEVIN LEVIN I
LO LO HI RUBIO RUBIO HI
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI
VALLADARES BELLA THERE IS HIGH
THE VOTES ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO LEAVE IT OPEN IF THERE'S
ANY ABSENT MEMBERS ALLOWED OUT
AND WE WILL NOW GO TO CONSENT
ITEMS OKAY I NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND. MOTION MOVED BY MISS
RUBIO SECOND BY MISTER LEVY. S.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MEDINA HI MEDINA I JULY NINTH
JULY HI A ROMULAN ROMULUS HIGH
BLOOM. BLOOM I GAVE REAL
GABRIEL I- WHEN- WHEN I'D
HIGHLY HIGHLY I LEVIN LEVIN I
LO LO I RUBIO RUBIO II SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I BALLADARES
VALLADARES HI THE LOTUS TWELVE
ZERO ZERO CONSENT ITEMS ARE
APPROVED WE'LL GO BACK TO- ADD
ONS YES BILL GOOD ON CALL YES
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. SEVEN FIVE
SIX I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. MOVED BY MR BLOOM
SECOND BY MISS RUBIO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA HI JULY. AT
AROUND ELEVEN EIGHT AROUND A
LOT I. BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL
APRIL I- WHEN. WHEN NOT VOTING
KYLIE. KYLIE NO LEVIN LEVIN HI
LO LOW I RUBIO RUBIO I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THERE THERE. THERE
THERE IS A HIGH. THAT IS NINE
ONE IS OUT YES. FILE ITEM.
THREE EIGHTY NINE TO EIGHT I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOVED BY MS RUBIO SECOND BY
MISTER BLOOM. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHILE. A ROMULAN
AROUND A LOT I BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL. GABRIEL HI- WHEN- WHEN
I HIGHLY KYLIE HI LEVIN. LEVIN
I LO LO I RUBIO RUBIO I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I BALLADARES
VALLADARES HI THE VOTE IS
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO BILL IS
OUT. PHYLUM FOR A. B. ELEVEN
ELEVEN I MADE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. MOVED BY MR LEVINE
SECOND BY MISTER BLUE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI CHARLIE AROUND A
LOT. AROUND A LOT I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I-
WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY KYLIE I
LOVE BEING. LEVIN I RUBIO RUBIO
I LO LO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
VALLADARES VALLADARES HI THE
VOTE IS ELEVEN ZERO ZERO
VILLAGE OUT. FILE ITEM FIVE
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT NINE I NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND MOVE BY MR
LEVIN. SECOND BY MS RUBIO OKAY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI. HI AROUND A LOT AROUND A
LOT I BLOOM. BLOOM HI GABRIEL
DAVID L. I- WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY.
HIGHLY NARROWLEVIN LEVIN HI LO
LO I RUBIO RUBIO HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO YOU KNOW COMMITTEE
SANTIAGO I GOT A GAS WELL THERE
IS I. JULY YES- SO SORRY I
WROTE ABOUT THE LIVES OF LATINO
FULL ITEMS- NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHT NINE OKAY IF YOU CAN
NOT TELL ME THE ITEM NUMBER
FIRST FIVE NUMBER FIVE NUMBER.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO EIGHT NINE YEAH
YES. CHOI HI THAT IS ELEVEN ONE
ELEVEN ONE THAT BILL IS OUT. K.
THING ITEM. SIX EIGHTY ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE I NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND. MARCIA BUT MS RUBY-
SECOND BY. ME MR CHOICE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
MEDINA HI JOY HI JOY HI A
ROMULAN AROUND A LOT I BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL GABRIEL I-
WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY. KYLIE HI
LEVIN LEVIN I LO LO I RUBIO
RUBIO HI SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
BALLADARES ELDERS HI LOTUS
TWELVE ZERO ZERO BELIEVES OUT.
I AM. SEVEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN I HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. BY MISTER SANTIAGO
SECOND BY MISTER BLUE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEDINA HI
MEDINA I JOY. CHILE HI A
ROMULAN. AROUND A LOT HI BLOOM.
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL II-
WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY. KYLIE NOT
VOTING LEVIN LEVIN HI LO LOW I
RUBIO. RUBIO I. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I VALLADARES. WELL
THERE'S NOT VOTING THE VOTE IS
TEN ZERO TEN ZERO THOSE OUT.
PHYLUM EIGHT AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. MOVED BY MISTER LOWE
SECOND BY MS RUBIO. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I JULY ON JULY HI A
ROMULAN AROUND A LOT I BLAME.
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL I-
WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY KYLIE HI
LEVIN LEVIN I LOVE. LOW HI
RUBIO RUBIO HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI VALLADARES BELT
THERE IS HI LOTUS TWELVE ZERO
POSER BELIEVES UP. I DON'T.
NINE EIGHTY THREE SIX SEVEN. C.
AROUND A LOT. AROUND A LOT I DO
YOU THE MOST NO. APRIL GABRIEL
I- WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY. KYLIE
HI SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI. THE
VOTE IS ELEVEN ZERO ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM. TEN
EIGHTY NINETY NINE. ARAMBULA
AROUND A LOT HI GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I HIGHLY KYLIE HI LO
LOW I RUBIO RUBIO I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE IS TWELVE
ZERO TWELVE ZERO BUILDS UP.
PHYLUM ELEVEN AB. ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN. ARAMBULA AROUND A LOT
HI GABRIEL GABRIEL I- WHEN-
WHEN I HIGHLY KYLIE NO LEVIN.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO II. THE VOTE
IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT ONE THAT
BUILDS UP. FILE ITEM. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE TWO SEVEN. ARAMBULA.
AROUND A LOT HI GABRIEL. APRIL
I HIGHLY. KYLIE NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE
IS ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX.
RUBIO RUBIO HI THE VOTE IS TEN
ZERO TEN ZERO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN AB. SEVENTY FIVE.
ARAMBULA AROUND A LOT HI
GABRIEL. APRIL I HIGHLY. KYLIE
NOT VOTING RUBIO RUBIO HI. THAT
IS. TEN ZERO ZERO ZERO. FILE
ITEM IN EIGHTEEN AB TWELVE
SIXTEEN. APRIL APRIL I HIGHLY.
CORRECT I'M SORRY I HIGHLY I
RUBIO RUBIO HI THE VOTE IS
TWELVE ZERO TWELVE ZERO THE
BUILDERS OUT HANG ON. THIS IS
YOUR CLOTHING YEAH. OKAY I
THINK VIALS ITEM ONE A. B.
SEVEN FIVE SIX ALL RIGHT NOW.
NUMBER ONE NO. YEAH. WHATEVER
THAT MEANS YOU MISSED IT I
THINK IT IS IT IS THAT WE WERE
NOT IN THE VOTING YEAH THE FIRM
CORRECT YES SO WHILE I AM ONE
SEVEN FIVE SIX SOME OF THEM.
WITH SOMEONE WITH. NO I DON'T
HAVE YOUR NUMBER ONE ON EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE SIX. FIRST ONE
STEVE. BUT FIRST LET US KNOW.
NO H. I KNOW SO THE VOTE IS.
NINE TWO. THOSE OUT YES AND
FILE ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN
EIGHT CHARLIE. CHOI I THE VOTE
IS TWELVE ZERO. FILE ITEM FOR
A. B. E. ELEVEN ELEVEN. CHOI I.
THE VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO. YEAH
C. N. I THINK THAT. ARE YOU
THINKING IN THE SECOND QUARTER
ARE YOU. I WANT TO MAKE. I
THINK YOU GOT EVERYTHING YEAH
YEAH WE WENT THROUGH IT ALL
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
EVERYTHING FOR DAYCARE. ALL
RIGHT I HAVE SENT. YEAH YEAH
THAT WAS A MISTAKE RIGHT IN I
HOPE WE WERE VOTED ON BUT WE-
IRAN IS.